Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, die Wahl naht und die Wahlversprechen werden immer schöner.
Jo, die CDU Berlin hat jetzt Stadt freies, kostenloses WLAN surfen angeboten.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer vierhundertundsieben. Ja, was haben wir denn heute? Den dreiundzwanzig. September 202ein. Genau.
Und das ist der Tag, an dem es wie viele Jahrzehnte her ist, dass du WLAN surfen warst, Tim? Wann warst du letzte Mal WLAN surfen?
Ey, ich konnte das Wort surfen, noch nie leiden irgendwie. Das war für mich das erste Wort, was mir eigentlich immer wieder klargemacht hat, dass die anderen nie wissen, wovon sie reden.
Die schweißen sich für uns in die Wellen.
Also es ist wirklich surfen. Ich wollte nie surfen aufm Netz. Ich wollte im Netz tauchen,
Ach so,
mich hat immer nur der interessiert so, aber so dieses an der Oberfläche bleiben lässt, das äh scheint bei den anderen dann doch irgendwie sehr viel beliebter zu sein. Bloß nicht so tief in das Thema eintauchen
immer nur irgendwie oberflächlich agieren.
Und vor allem am Ende, wenn kaum eine Fahrt aufgenommen hast, am Ende auf jeden Fall reinfallen, nassen Arsch haben. Das ist Surfen.
Genau und mit der Fresse in Sand.
Genau richtige Surfer von der CDU.
Ja, diese diese Illusion auch irgendwie, man könnte funktionierendes, stadtweites WLAN äh hinbekommen, das irgendwie auch.
Ist ja schön, aber ähm ich sehe das noch nicht, das irgendwo wirklich mal jeweils gelingen wird. Äh.
Es braucht auch niemand mehr, sorry, wir haben.
Es braucht einfach für korrekte LTE-Tarife und fertig ist die Laube.
Macht fünf Geräten Scheiß also weißt du? Und und gerade in also in Berlin ist das so eine eine.
So lächerlich, ja? Ich meine, Berlin, vielleicht kurz als Hintergrund, ne, die sogenannten Opal-Ghettos. Wir haben hier schon öfter mal drüber gesprochen, wo sie ähm.
Irgendwann 90er Jahren optische Anschlussleitungen gelegt haben und dann nicht in der Lage, also Fiber to the Home, ja.
Eigentlich eine super Idee.
Genau und dann haben sie aber irgendwie nicht hingekriegt, die zu versorgen, weil sie am Ende nach der Fiber wieder auf Kupfer äh ähm modulieren mussten. Irgendein Teil haben sie da nie hingekriegt.
Das war ihnen einfach zu teuer, weil sie halt von der DSL-Revolution aus der USA überholt wurden. USA äh haben sie natürlich solche Ziele nie gehabt,
Glasfaser nach Hause, sondern war immer alles Kupfer und Modem und so weiter. Und dann ist es ja direkt auf DSL gegangen und da ist dann der Markt drauf gesprungen und dann war das halt alles billig
aber die ganzen optischen Boxen waren ihnen dann zu teuer und dann wollten sie das nicht mehr durchziehen.
Ja und das hatte zur Konsequenz, dass du hier noch äh Anfang der Zweitausender große Teile Berlins hattest, in denen du kein ernst zu nehmendes Tier selber kommen hast. Und ähm,
mussten dann die Straßen aufreißen und der Kupfer reinwerfen, damit ähm damit du hier irgendwann,
wie der WLAN wieder wieder DSL haben konnte, ist überhaupt, dass du das bestellen konntest, ja? Ich hab hier teilweise in Berlin gewohnt und bin mit 'n sechsundfünfzig K Mo, dem online gegangen, weil das die einzige Möglichkeit war.
In dieser Zeit, ja, irgendwann Ende Neunziger, Anfang Zweitausender,
hat sich in Berlin diese Freifunk-Community eben auch so stark ähm gemacht, die dann eben gesagt hat, okay, da wo das Internet ist,
äh da da holen wir es und verteilen es über den Dächern von Berlin in die in die dunklen Teile der Stadt,
Und äh ne, machen einen, machen einen, machen Freifunk, ja? Und zwar Freifunk nicht nur als Jo, hier ist ein WLAN Kanzler rein, sondern als Erschließen,
ähm von nicht Internet angebundenen Regionen Berlins, den Kern der Stadt, im S-Bahn-Ring. Ja, das, das, das war,
Freifunk hier zumindest in Berlin in in großen Teilen oder in wichtigen Teilen der Stadt. Und gleichzeitig, ich mein,
was die CDU hier auch noch bewirkt, ist es es soll dann WLAN in der U-Bahn geben, sogar in der U-Bahn, ja, schöne Sache, ja, in vielen anderen Städten gibt's einfach fickendes LTE in der U-Bahn, ja? Das kannst du in Berlin abhaken,
haben wir auch nicht. Ja, ich ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich glaube, hier O2 bietet das an oder so, ne, aber.
Ich glaube, ich bin jetzt schon länger nicht mehr U-Bahn gefahren, aber das ist das, dabei treibst du jetzt so ein bisschen, also.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, übertreibe ich nicht. Wenn du mich kürzlich U-Bahn gefahren und habe das äh wieder in Anspruch nehmen können, diese diese äh wunderschöne Situation. Und es gibt jetzt, das ist jetzt ungefähr seit, ich würde sagen, zwei Jahren.
Können auch zweieinhalb oder drei sein. Gibt es ja tatsächlich BVG Hotspots. Ja, also die Berliner Verkehrsbetriebe haben einen U-Bahn-WLAN gebaut, ja?
Mit des Unternehmens Hotspots, ähm dass dann das ist zumindest das Skeptive Port, äh was man da anklickt. Und dieses U-Bahn-WLAN, was es ja jetzt schon gibt, ne, ist eins A funktioniert,
In jedem U-Bahnhof, ja, aber nicht dazwischen. Es ist, also ich meine, diese Stadt ist so,
Katastrophe. Und aber vor dem Hintergrund zu sagen, ey jo, wir wir bekämpfen seit zwei Jahrzehnten aktiv mit jeder Faser, die wir in unserem Körper haben, Freifunk.
Wir äh machen denen das Leben schwer mit der Störerhaftung äh und was nicht alles, ja? Äh jetzt zu sagen, ey jo voll geil, wir haben hundert Ideen für Berlin. Hier ist ET siebenundneunzig, WLAN.
In einer dreieinhalb Millionen Personen statt.
Mann ey, wirklich. Das ist so peinlich. Ich finde das so peinlich. Mir fällt da auch gar nichts mehr zu ein, weil das einfach nur so peinlich ist.
Dafür, dass dir nix so einfällt. Das ist aber ganz schön lange dadrüber. Lass uns das äh einfach ignorieren.
Ich rede auch, nee, ich ich ignoriere das nicht. Ich möchte an dieser Stelle noch einmal sicherstellen, dass sich niemand hier unter den Hörerinnen auch nur mit dem Gedanken anfreundet, egal unter welchen Gründen oder Umständen diese Partei zu wählen,
oder die AfD,
AfD kommt eh nicht in Frage, brauche ich, glaube ich, keinen mehr von abzuhalten. Bei der CDU bin ich nicht sicher, ob da alle unsere Hörerinnen wirklich geistig so gefestigt sind, dass sie das, dass sie wissen, dass das kategorisch auszuschließen ist. Deswegen wollte ich das nochmal kurz wiederholen.
Ja, aber du weißt natürlich auch, dass bei dem digitalen Thema ist jetzt auch nicht so viel andere Parteien gibt, die dann irgendeiner Form besonders hervorgestochen werden mit kreativen Vorschlägen und ich glaube, derzeit hat das noch überhaupt gar keiner verstanden, wie man diesen Ausbau wirklich äh voranbringt.
Egal.
Vier null sieben.
Ja, wir müssen das kurz erwähnen, ne. Also äh ist ja Lokbuch vier null sieben. Wir haben ja äh angekündigt, dass wir alle ähm alle Fehlermeldungen oder alle Status kurz, wie das so schön heißt, vorstellen.
Heute ist richtig langweilig. Heute ja Code vier null sieben das sind so Fehlermeldungen, die,
die Nutzerin liebt, ja, klickst irgendwo drauf rum und dann kriegst du irgendwie so was. Hä? Keine Ahnung,
ist, glaube ich, auch diese Meldung als solche, ist viel zu technisch, aber.
Es wäre vielleicht mal ganz interessant, dass man dieses schöne Wort Proxi mal kurz äh aufdröselt. Ich weiß gar nicht, ist das überhaupt noch ein Ding?
In Unternehmen wahrscheinlich, ne. Ja.
Äh du äh tatsächlich in äh sehr viel größerem Maße als ähm du jetzt dir vielleicht ähm,
spontan vorstellst, weil ähm viele ähm Webaplikationen ja heute zum Beispiel in,
ähm pfeifen oder ähnlichen Dingern geschrieben werden und ähm also Django oder solchen Dingen und häufig,
ähm werden die quasi mit einem lokalen, abgespeckten Webserver äh auf einem,
oder so angeboten und es ist nicht unüblich, da nochmal einen Enginex vorzuhauen und der der ist dann tatsächlich in einem Proxi-Modus davor.
Und ähm damit du sicherstellen kannst, dass äh vielleicht nicht jemand direkt auf diese Web-App zugreift, weil du das nicht möchtest. Ähm legst du unter Umständen auch einfach eine eine zwischen der Web-App
und dem.
Linus, du hast jetzt schon wieder 50 Prozent unserer Hörerinnen äh abgekoppelt. Also.
Ja, ich habe ja auch mit dir geredet, Tim.
Ja, mir musste noch nichts erklären. Also wahrscheinlich werdet ihr das Wort
Proxy schon mal gehört haben und Proxi ist halt
quasi so ein, ne, so ein, also vom Wortsinne her eher so ein so ein Platzhalter und im im Internet ist das halt einfach ein eine eine Zwischengeschaltete Entität, die dir quasi vorgesetzt wird, bevor du wirklich ans Internet rankommst, sprich in so
äh Situationen, wie in einem Unternehmen oder so, war das äh oft,
Gang und Geber auch also aus Performance äh äh Gründen. So ein Proxi, so ein Stadthalter davor zu schalten. Sprich, wenn man irgendwo im Web herumklickt,
dann ähm landet man erstmal bei diesem Proxi, der
weil sie so am am Internetzugang des Unternehmens angesiedelt ist. Und nur durch diesen Proxi hindurch kann man dann auf das Web
zugreifen. Und das macht immer irgendwie Ärger und das ist immer irgendwie nervig und anstrengend. Und dann gibt's dann halt auch mal solche Fehlermeldungen, wenn man sich dann gegenüber diesem Proxi vielleicht auch nochmal äh
ja anmelden muss, authentifizieren muss und dafür sind dann so komische Status kurz wie vier nullsieben gedacht,
in meinem Leben noch nicht äh viel mit zu tun gehabt mit dieser Fehlermeldung, aber äh geben tut sowas auf jeden Fall. Praxis nerven aber.
Dieses ähm Corporating, was du da benennst, ne? Das ist tatsächlich sehr häufig. Ähm.
Die die die nageln quasi alle Leitungen zum Internet dicht und sagen, okay, keiner darf hier sich irgendwohin verbinden,
und wenn du ins Internet gehen möchtest, dann machst du es bitte durch unseren Proxi. Und damit,
Jetzt zum Beispiel eine Schadsoftware, die sich nach draußen verbinden möchte, nicht ohne Weiteres, einfach sofort über den Proxi
raus kann, ähm braucht es quasi eine authentication
Und dann hättest du jetzt quasi so einen typischen Unternehmensnetzwerk, steht da dein Rechner und der ist konfiguriert, einen Proxi zu nutzen und zwar mit deiner Nutzername Passwort Kombination, die,
natürlich nebenbei auch noch den Effekt hat, dich auf dem Proxi identifizierbar zu machen und der Proxi macht dann so Sachen wie zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt,
alle die ganze Zeit. Google dot com, aufrufen, das Bild, was dort ist, äh vielleicht auch zum Beispiel mal lokal zu cashen und bei verschlüsselten Verbindungen.
Zu versuchen, äh sich dazwischen zu schalten, dass du eben ähm dass du quasi die Verschlüsselung gegenüber diesem Proxi verlierst, damit der ähm deinen Traffic auf potenziell,
ungewünschtes äh Verhalten kontrollieren kann. Ähm andererseits werden Proxis auch gerne benutzt, um äh irgendwie Georstriktionen zu umgehen, ne, Netflix gucken,
Solche Dinge. Also es ist schon eine,
Technologie, die sehr, die viele unterschiedliche Anwendungszwecke hat, unter anderem eben auch einen lokalen Proxi vor eine vor eine Web-App schalten, um um von der ein bisschen die Last runterzunehmen oder so.
Aber ist natürlich auch ein bisschen das Gegenteil von Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, ne.
In den in den Unternehmensdingen auf jeden Fall, klar. Und da.
Da schlagen natürlich zwei Herzen in in der Brust, ja ähm.
Die eine Sache ist, wenn du heutzutage sagst, du Firewalls irgendwie allen Traffic, ne? Und lässt aber jetzt irgendwie achtzig und vier vier drei, weil es Web ist durch,
musst du eben damit leben, dass das ein dass das weit verbreitetste Protokoll ist, über das alles funktioniert und alles getunnelt werden kann und dass du damit dir eigentlich auch die Firewall sparen könntest.
Insofern natürlich aus einer Security-Perspektive will eine große Organisation, die viele Rechner,
ja, schützen und verwalten muss, zum Beispiel so etwas da drauf haben, wie so ein Schadsoftware-Scanner oder ein Filter auf auf bestimmte Inhalte, ne?
Ähm dass diese Technologie gleichzeitig auch eine Überwachungstechnologie sein kann und ist,
und eine Zensurtechnologie ist eben einer der,
unschönen ähm Seiten davon, ne? Proxi ist nicht grundsätzlich schlecht und ein Proxis auch nicht grundsätzlich gut. Ist halt eine Technologie, die bestimmte Dinge ermöglicht. Einige davon können durchaus in deinem Interesse sein, ähm andere eher nicht.
Ja
Nun gut, ich würde vorschlagen, wir gehen mal aufs Feedback dieser letzten Sendung.
Ja, ich hatte in der letzten Sendung ja erzählt, dass ich mich als Wahlhelfer gemeldet habe dann im Mai einen Brief bekommen habe und seitdem nichts mehr gehört habe, haben sich auch sehr viele Leute in den Kommentaren gemeldet, denen es ähnlich erging
Und ich habe jetzt am 18. September, also ähm würde ich jetzt mal sagen, äh also acht Tage vor der Wahl.
Habe ich eine habe ich per E-Mail ein PDF bekommen, in dem sich quasi mein Einberufungsbescheid äh befindet, wann ich wo zu sein habe, zu welcher Tätigkeit und welche online Lehrgänge ich vorher absolvieren soll
und dann wurde gesagt, ja und irgendwie dem Wahlvorstand würde jetzt ähm.
Meine E-Mail-Adresse mitgeteilt, damit er sich bei mir melden kann. Wenn ich da was gegen hätte, soll ich bitte ein Einwand erheben.
Wo ich auch so dachte, ach so, äh eigentlich hatte ich immer den Eindruck, dass ich Zustimmung erteilen muss und nicht Einwand, wenn meine Daten weitergegeben werden. Und äh ja, einen Tag später oder zwei, bekomme ich dann von irgend so einer Web DE, E-Mail-Adresse,
mit äh weiß ich nicht, sechs Leuten CC,
eine freundliche Mail von jemandem, der so hallo zusammen, schön, dass sie am Sonntag unser Team verstärkt. Viele Grüße gesendet mit der,
Web DE App. Wo ich auch denke so, super geil. Fängt an mit einem zumindest sagen wir mal DSGVO,
zweifelhaften Verfahren, der sich jetzt irgendwelche komischen E-Mail-Adressen hier habe. Ähm einmal die, die CC waren und dann eben andere, an die das vorher auch schon mal geschickt hat,
die Mail irgendwie weitergeleitet hat.
Na ja und dann bin ich auch sehr gespannt, wie das wird. Dann steht da drin, ich soll bitte von vierzehn bis achtzehn Uhr da sein.
Sag mal, steht denn da eigentlich wirklich Einberufungsbescheid drauf? Nein. Das hast du jetzt so genannt. Das kann ich mir ja kaum vorstellen.
Ich muss mal gucken. Warte mal, ich gucke mal ganz kurz.
Es klingt ja so ein bisschen wie Bundeswehr.
Einberufung in einen Briefwahlvorstand. Ja, natürlich, das ist ja auch Bundeswehr. Ich habe ja jetzt, ich habe ja auch alle Rechte verwirkt, um mich dem noch zu entziehen. Hm, nur mit wichtigem Grund.
Okay. Musste dann auch in Uniform antreten.
Über Kleidung steht hier nix. Aber die haben mich ja auch äh also wenn ich das richtig verstehe, bin ich Briefwahl.
Also ich werde die da jetzt nicht im Kundenkontakt stehen und dann auch so eine geile Sache. Ich meine, du denkst natürlich, du willst irgendwie planen, ja? Und dann steht hier.
Wir verpflichten Sie Pipapo über die Tatsachen, Geheimnis unterliegen, irgendwas ähm.
Und auf jeden Fall steht da auch.
Irgend so eine E-Learning-Plattform, Benutzername, was man auf jeden Fall auch sage ich mal so wie man das von Wahlen kennt. Und dann stand hier irgendwo was, dass mein Einsatz eben von, genau, mh.
Wir bilden sie daher, sich am Wahltag zu dieser Uhrzeit 14 bis 18 Uhr in dem oben benannten Briefwahlraum einzufinden,
So, okay, alles klar, 14 bis achtzehn Uhr, komme ich kein Thema.
Nach Schließung der Wahllokale um 18 Uhr folgt die Auszählung der abgegebenen Stimmen. Bitte planen sie also auch hier noch ausreichend Zeit ein. Ja, ich mein, ich verstehe, dass sie mir nicht sagen können, wie lange das,
weil sie nicht wissen, wie viel Briefwahl da liegt, ne? Aber dann sagt doch einfach, weißt du, planen sie noch ausreichend Zeit ein. Sagt doch bitte, wie viel. Wie lange hat es letztes Jahr gedauert? Hat es zwei Stunden gedauert oder vier oder acht? Weiß also so,
Na ja, ist auch egal. Also es.
Du musst vier Stunden vorher da sein, aber hast du eigentlich in in der Zeit gar nichts zu tun?
Ja, ich habe nicht auch gewundert, was ich da mache und mein Verdacht ist, also mein Verdacht.
Das ist jetzt Spekulation. Ich habe auch diese E-Learning Sachen nicht gemacht, weil die sehen aus, die sehen aus wie fisching Links, da klicke ich nicht drauf, ja. Aber ähm wenn ich das, also meine Vermutung ist, dass wir die ähm Briefwahldinger aufmachen, aber nur den ersten Umschlag
und dann irgendwie sagen, okay, was weiß ich, ist diese Person, die hier gerade, ne, ist, die muss ja irgendwie diese.
Die Verifizierung der Person, genau, darf die überhaupt fehlen? Und dann geht.
Genau und dann,
dass wir diese diese blauen Umschläge oder welche Farbe die dann hatten, dass wir die dann quasi irgendwo in eine Urne werfen oder so was, ne? Und dann äh ab achtzehn Uhr äh die auszählen dürfen,
Das wäre jetzt so meine meine Vermutung. Aber wie gesagt, diese äh E-Learning-Plattform, sorry, das äh sieht irgendwie nicht, das sieht nicht äh gut aus.
Aber wenn du jetzt da nicht lernst online, dann weiß ja nichts, wenn du.
Oh mein Gott, das ist auch so geil. Also die haben ja einen Benutzernamen gegeben und ein Passwort. Und ich sehe gerade, ich kann das Passwort ändern. Soll ich mal.
Wie jetzt für alle.
Sind auf jeden Fall ist der Benutzername, den ich da bekommen habe, nicht ähm nicht auf mich persönlich abgestimmt.
Mhm. Verstehe. Na ja, okay.
Ich bin der Wahlhelfer.
Genug Potenzial, um sozusagen auch mh nicht unbedingt äh behilflich zu sein. Ist deine.
Vor allem steht hier. Ich muss den Kurs drei machen. Briefwahllokal. Öffnen. Ich mache das mal eben.
Kurs starten. Aufgaben, Stimmzettel auszählen. Hm, mache ich.
Transportbehälter gibt es. Ich bin muss unparteiisch und verschwiegen sein,
Was heißt die unparteiisch? Ich bin nicht unparteiisch. CDU-Stimmen werden sofort weggeworfen,
Nein, das darf man nicht sagen. Nein, da darf man sich auch nicht bei erwischen lassen, das ist äh relativ klar. Ah ja und dann steht hier irgendwie mit dem Wahlbrief und so. Das gucke ich mir nochmal an in Ruhe. Ja, also mache ich am Sonntag. Aber super.
Acht Tage vorher Bescheid zu bekommen. Wir wussten ja auch, er ist kurzfristig, dass diese Wahl stattfindet.
Also, ich glaube, vielen Leuten ist das erst in den letzten Tagen wirklich bewusst geworden,
bin überhaupt, wenn überhaupt.
Okay, diese, das ist hier, warte mal, wie viele Folien sind das hier? Dreiunddreißig Folien, okay, nicht fünfhundert. Oh, jetzt habe ich aus Versehen auf die letzte Folie geklickt, jetzt bin ich schon durch. Ah, ich muss ein Quiz machen.
Aussagen sind korrekt. Am Tag vor der Wahl nehme die Wahlvorstehende Person des Briefwahllokals beim Bezirkswahlamt das Wahlmaterial in Transportbehältern entgegen. Weiß ich nicht, muss ich nur mal gucken.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das stimmt. Schon durchgefallen. Vielleicht komme ich aus der Nummer raus, wenn ich jetzt einfach hier die Fragen falsch beantworte.
Genau. Wie gehen sie mit den Stimmen um? Ja, die von der CDU, die lege ich dann in Mülleimer. Oh.
Die Guten. Die guten, die Guten in die Urne, die schlechten in den Müll. Ja.
Na ja, gut, dass du das jetzt nur mir gegenüber so geäußert hast und nicht irgendwie in der Öffentlichkeit verbreitet hast.
Ja, die werden ja wohl, die werden ja wohl nicht Zweifel an meiner Unparteilichkeit.
Ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht, auf welcher Basis.
Okay, lass uns äh weiter.
Bin auf jeden Fall sehr gespannt, ja. Ich äh war eigentlich davon ausgegangen, dass ich das nicht mehr machen muss und musste jetzt auch entsprechend nochmal andere Reisepläne buchen, aber äh ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, ob äh ich vielleicht.
Ja, deine Erfahrungen können wir dann hier auf jeden Fall äh teilen. Ich werde dir dann erzählen, wie's mir im Wahllokal ergangen ist.
Ja und dann äh natürlich, weil das hatte ich hier, glaube ich, nur so am Rande erwähnt, weil das natürlich auch einfach nur,
Ein großer Anlass von Schmerz ist, vor vier Jahren hatten wir ja, also bei der Bundestagswahl zwanzig1sieb.
Hatten ja Martin Schirsig, Torsten Schröder und ich uns mit der Wahlsoftware auseinandergesetzt und da äh gravierende Schwachstellen festgestellt, nicht nur in der Software selber, sondern eben auch, wie die betrieben wird beispielsweise, in,
Hessen und ähm dann haben wir natürlich sehr darauf gehofft, haben wir einen relativ großen
Katalog mit Vorschlägen auch geschrieben, was an gegen welche Sicherheitsprinzipien mit dieser Software verstoßen wurde und wie man ähm denen begegnen könnte, um eine sinnvolle Wahl
oder eine sichere Wahl abzuhalten. Und natürlich von, ja, letztendlich keine dieser ähm Anforderungen umgesetzt. Es gab,
tatsächlich keine Auditierung von Wahlsoftware. Ähm es gab es gibt keine Vorschrift,
für Wahlsoftware, ja, das BSI hätte ja zum Beispiel sagen können, pass auf, sowas nehmen wir nicht, hier ist eine technische Richtlinie, was eine Wahlsoftware sicherzustellen hat. Das ist alles nicht passiert. Es gibt jetzt nur irgendwie so eine Empfehlung zum
zum sicheren Betrieb, ja, wo dann irgendwie für die ähm für die kommunalen Dienstleister oder die Wahllokale irgendwie äh
vorgeschrieben wird, wie die Software zu betreiben ist. Ähm gab ja auch noch mal eine Anfrage auf frag den Staat, äh quasi so, habt ihr da irgendetwas gemacht, um die Zustand dieser Software zu verbessern? Und die Antwort ist ähm einfach nein.
Das ist natürlich auch sehr ernüchternd. Insofern bin ich mal sehr gespannt, ob ich da noch mit irgendeiner Software in Kontakt komme.
Ja, also den Prozess solltest du natürlich auf jeden Fall äh komplett mitverfolgen, das musst dir wahrscheinlich gar nicht sagen, das dürfte wirklich sehr interessant sein, zu sehen, wer sich da eigentlich auf welche Art und Weise, welche Ergebnisse notiert und äh zu welchem Zeitpunkt, an wen,
wie weiterleitet.
Das muss auf jeden Fall mal ordentlich debatt werden. So, weiter geht's. Es gab noch Feedback zu den Purabos.
Ja und zwar, das war ja eine der der für mich doch sehr interessanten Erkenntnisse, die ich äh das Thema ja vor zwei Sendungen oder so und dann hatten wir ja schon mal ein Feedback dazu.
Ähm dessen Tenor ja im Prinzip war, dass die Puras gar nicht das Ziel haben, dass jemand das Pur-Abo abschließt,
sondern das Ziel haben, dass die Menschen die vollumfängliche Zustimmung geben zum Tracking. Und ähm,
der äh Kommentar, den wir in der letzten Sendung äh verlesen haben, der schildert hier auch so ein bisschen das
dass man das auch daran erkennt, dass die nicht automatisch verlängern, dass die nirgendwo sonst aktiv beworben werden, sobald es jemand äh sobald
quasi man einmal weggeklickt hat, ne, während die plus Abos ja überall beworben werden, sodass es quasi konkret nicht das Interesse besteht. Da haben wir noch einen Kommentar, den ich letzte Mal nicht verlesen habe.
Den ich an der Stelle äh,
nochmal äh mit würdigen möchte. Und zwar von dem macht was mit Medien Gig. Ähm hi zusammen, da kann ich doch mal was beitragen. Ich arbeite in einem großen Zeitungsmedienverlag und zwar in dem Team, dass unser Pur-Abo entwickelt hat,
Und ich könnte da ein bisschen Einblick geben. Ihr habt schon richtig vermutet, dass der Preis natürlich total überteuert ist.
Laut den Zahlen, die ich kenne, um Faktor 50 bis 100. Und das eine der Absichten ist, nicht neue Kunden zu gewinnen, sondern einfach die DSG,
VO-Einwilligung der User zu erzwingen. Ja, beides ist ja auch spezifisch Kern der Beschwerde von Noib,
Wie so oft ist es leider aber noch schlimmer. Erstens, im Verlag wird pur nicht als weiteres Produkt gesehen
mit dem wir Geld verdienen wollen. Im Gegenteil ist es teilweise so, dass man sogar
gar keine Purnutzer haben will. Deshalb wird das nach der DSGVO Zuströmung auch nicht mehr beworben. Der Preis ist eh so hoch, dass wir nie genug Nutzer dafür bekämen, dass sich die Entwicklung rentieren würde,
es sind Kosten, die abgeschrieben werden, um den Werbeumsatz zu stützen.
Zweitens, alle der Beteiligten gingen schon vor Produktstart davon aus, dass dieses Angebot illegal ist und die DSGVO verletzt
Das war aber aus Sicht des Verlages auch nie nötig, etwas Legales anzubieten. Es war nur nötig, dass man notfalls vor Gericht sagen könnte, dass man darauf,
dass man dachte, dass es legal ist und dass man sich nicht sicher war. Der Ablauf bei diesen Dingen ist immer der Gleiche. Irgendein Verlag denkt sich so eine Idee aus und nach und nach kopieren alle anderen, die bis alle das haben. Wir gehen fest davon aus.
Dass das weggeklagt wird, aber es dauert ja eine Zeit, bis wirklich mal jemand klagt und dann noch Jahre bis das Urteil kommt. Außerdem ist die Hoffnung groß, dass wenn alle das einsetzen, unser Verlag,
einfach nicht als Erster verklagt wird. Wenn dann das Urteil kommt, baut man das halt wieder aus.
Ärgern tut sich aber von den Verantwortlichen niemand und es wird als erfolgreiches Projekt gesehen, denn man hat ja viele Jahre damit gutes Geld verdient,
und dann geht alles wieder von vorne los mit der nächsten Idee. Im Grunde ist es der gleiche Hintergrund wie im Mobilfunkmarkt mit
Stream on und Vodafone Past. Ein weiterer Fun Fact dazu. Wir hatten vor kurzem eine Datenschutzschulung. Allerdings waren wir dann sehr verblüfft, als die Schulung zu einem Teil daraus bestand, dass ein Jurist,
Umgehungen der DSGVO vorgestellt hat, bei denen er davon ausgeht, dass wir nicht die Ersten wären, die man verklagen würde, weil die Konkurrenz ja noch dreister
das Gesetz verletzt. Als wir fragten, ob das nicht die DSGVO verletzt, was er ja schon indirekt zugegeben hatte, kam das Money Quote der Schulung,
Wenn man sich an Gesetze halten,
Wenn sie sich an Gesetze halten wollen, sind sie leider in der falschen Branche. Das fastet zurecht gut zusammen. Lieben Gruß und macht weiter so. Gute Arbeit, LNP ist mein Lieblings-Podcast.
Und das finde ich natürlich schon sehr äh interessant. Ähm.
Das war mir in der Form tatsächlich nicht klar und das äh also erstens, dass sie diese Zwecke erfüllen und dass das eben auch offenbar,
kein Geheimnis, in den Verlagen ist, dass dass der Zweck dieser Pur-Abos ist. Insofern auch schön, dass neue Psych darum kümmert.
Ist schon echt krass irgendwie. Also überraschend tut's mich jetzt nicht, aber ist trotzdem krass. Muss man sich auch echt überlegen, ob man in so einer Branche arbeiten will, ey.
Ich finde es eh leid, also so ein bisschen äh schade natürlich auch, dass die ähm.
Also diese Plus-Abos sind ja leider auch ein bisschen teuer. Hm.
Ähm das ist eine traurige Situation. Ich meine, ich würde ja gerne, ich zahle auch bei einigen tatsächlich für diese Abos ähm für diese,
nicht pur Abos, sondern plus Abos, wo man dann die Inhalte wieder sehen darf, die dann auf der Seite veröffentlicht werden.
Ja, das ist in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch sag mal, ein fairer,
Deal. Ja, also ich meine, ob der Preis angemessen ist, muss dann jeder für sich selber entscheiden, aber ich ich finde halt so dieses entweder man nimmt irgendwo an diesem öffentlichen Ding äh teil,
oder man kauft sich die Inhalte, aber dann hat man irgendwie auch Ruhe. Ja, das fände ich halt irgendwie auch besser. Aber na ja, Gott, jetzt wissen wir, wie es ist. Ähm,
nicht genug Geld damit verdient offensichtlich. Ähm mit diesen Payballs und das ist natürlich auch, ich sehe das ja auch, habe das auch letzte Mal hier schon gesagt, äh sehe das Problem, aber
Ich finde es halt einfach auch grade hochgradig ähm problematisch, dass so Unternehmen sich damit halt auch einfach ihren Ruf ruinieren.
Also heiser ist da irgendwie echt das beste Beispiel. Also wirklich ein Verlag, der schon immer sehr,
das Ohr an so einer ähm Szene dran hatte, die für diese ganzen Themen sehr sensitiv ist,
der hier auch Holger Bleich zum zu Gast und äh hatten da auch kurz drüber gesprochen, dass dass das ja eigentlich auch real ist so, aber dann,
dann irgendwie diese Webseite einem dann immer so und so, ja und hier und nochmal Einverständniserklärung, Pipapo und wir wollen dich dann doch lieber ein bisschen aushorchen,
tja, das, das, das kratzt dann dann auch sehr an der Marke. Uns kratzt aber wohl noch nicht genug an der Marke. Damit der mal ein anderer Umgang.
Bei rauskommt.
Ja okay, dann,
Haben wir ja in der vorletzten Sendung äh mal uns mit ähm,
mit Bullshit-Bingostudien auseinandergesetzt und was ich sehr schön finde ist, da gibt es jetzt eine Studie ähm von, Moment,
dem IW Köln,
das Institut der deutschen Wirtschaft, ja und die haben eine äh Studie gemacht, wo die auch denkt, Leute, analysiert wurden, also die haben sich Tweets angeguckt, ja? Und zwar,
welche Rolle digitale Verwaltung und Breitband aus,
in der digitalen Kommunikation von Bundestagsabgeordneten, Parteien und Fraktionen auf Twitter spielen. Dazu wurden die Tweets aller 555 Bundestagsabgeordneten mit einem Twitter-Account,
ähm,
untersucht. Ja, also dir, also alle 555 Bundestagsabgeordneten, die einen Twitter-Account haben, Zeitraum 24. September 217 bis 31. August 20 21.
Und jetzt pass auf analysiert wurden alle Tweets,
in denen die Begriffe Breitbandausbau und digitale Verwaltung alternativ Digitalisierung der Verwaltung und E-Goverment entweder per Hashtag oder im Text erwähnt wurden. Reine Retweets wurden nicht berücksichtigt.
So, 341 Tweets von 18 Abgeordneten flossen so in die Untersuchung ein.
Insgesamt 341 Tweets.
Ja
vier Jahre, vier Jahre, 555 Leute und die kommen auf ein N von 341, ja? Außerdem wurden 37 Tweets, der im Bundestag vertretenen Parteien sowie 45 Tweets der Bundestagsfraktion aus dem genannten Zeitraum,
mit den genannten Begriffen in die Analyse einbezogen. So und ich meine, das ist ja schon ähm,
sehr äh mag, mager, ja? Und jetzt twittert quasi die Autorin äh oder eine der Autoren, ist eine Autorin, Autorin. Die Autorin twittert,
eine der fleißigsten twitternden Bundestagsabgeordneten ist Anke D, Anke Domstedt-Berg. Doch auch sie twitterte in der abgelaufenen Legislatur nur 16 Mal zu Rauteball Breitbandausbau und raute digitale Verwaltung
mehr in unserer Studie. Ja und Link dann auf diese Studie. So. So, jetzt sehr schön. Antwortet halt, war Anke Dobscheid Berg,
und sagt, okay, die Studie ist erschreckend symplifizierend, denn als Digitalpolitikerin benutze ich natürlich differenziertere Ausdrücke, nicht bloß den für Twitter sowieso ungeeigneten, weil viel zu langen Begriff,
Band-Ausbau. Analog eGovermitt,
hier mal eine Auswahl als Fred. So, jetzt hat sie so ein Fred irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, über Teil neun, Teil zehn, Teil dreizehn, Teil vierzehn, Teil fünfzehn, wo sie einfach über den Breitbandausbau twittert, ohne Breitbandauswahl
zu sagen, ja? Zum Beispiel Tweets in den Breitband vorkommt.
Ist ein also du fragst dich wirklich äh na ja sehr sehr äh sehr lustig und ja ist halt einfach nur auch wieder eine.
Eine weitere äh Bullshit-Bingostudie und du fragst dich wirklich, was soll, warum macht ihr sowas, ne?
Zwei Begriffe und dann machst du dir schon die Mühe, von 555 Leuten, die Tweets zu scrapen, aber nicht die Mühe, auch nur für eine Mark mitzudenken und mal vielleicht ein paar related Begriffe zu nehmen, ne. Also das ist auch wirklich sehr ähm,
sehr ähm sehr schwach, ne? Wundert man sich nicht, dass irgendwie Leute gibt, die sagen, sie vertrauen der Wissenschaft irgendwie nicht, ne.
Na ja.
Ja ist das äh ist das überhaupt wissenschaftlich? Also das ist.
Nee, eben nicht. Das ist das ist wissensschädlich.
Ja gut.
Na ja, die Ökonomen und Ökonomen haben leider eh nicht so viel von.
Ja, ich meine Institut ist äh kein geschützter Begriff, ne. Institut kann sich äh jeder nennen. Könnten wir auch machen.
Nähe, das stimmt leider nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Nee, ähm weil sich durch Zufall, weil ähm mal ein.
Weil ich mal miterleben musste oder miterfahren habe, dass eine Firma, die sich Institut nennen wollte, äh quasi der diesen Begriff nicht zugestanden hat. Also du kannst nicht alles Institut nennen.
Muss irgendwie ein spezifischen ähm.
Man muss sehr spezifisch benannt sein, was für ein Institut oder was auch immer. Also klar, du kannst erst mal irgendwie alles Institut nennen, aber es gab in diesem, also ich kenne jetzt diesen einen Fall, wo das ähm,
nicht nicht angenommen wurde den Ladeninstitut zu nennen.
Also Wikipedia sagt dazu, äh seine Verwendung wird von der deutschen Rechtsprechung nur in bestimmten Fällen, bei denen es sich um eine eigenständige Rechtspersönlichkeit handelt, eingeschränkt. Darüber hinaus ist der Begriff jedoch nicht gesetzlich geschützt.
Okay, dann war das in dem Fall war's, glaube ich, eine GmbH oder was da die sich so nennen wollte. Aber ja. Ja, genau. Nicht, nicht überall, wo Wissenschaft drin ist, äh drauf steht, ist auch Wissenschaft drin. Wenn du Pech hast, erwischt du auch einfach nur Wissen schädlich.
Ja gut, aber wir könnten trotzdem noch unser Institut gründen. Und man könnte sich irgendeine schöne, flammende Bezeichnung äh.
Institut für Bullshit-Bingo Bashing.
Ja, genau, oder zur Wiederherstellung der reinen Wahrheit und Ordnung.
Ja, da sind wir wahrscheinlich spät dran. Ähm.
Meinst du? Tut mir zu spätestens, dass sie Wahrheit und Ordnung nicht mehr dahergestellt werden kann oder dass es die schon gibt.
Dass die nicht mehr hergestellt werden kann.
Na ja gut, kann man ja trotzdem noch mal ein Institut kunden. Gibt ja viele Institute, die irgendwas fordern, was also nicht mehr erreicht werden kann.
Wir haben in der letzten Sendung äh darüber gesprochen, dass ja Attila Hildmann seine Domains und Kanäle verloren hat, weil er die irgendeinem Admin überschrieben hat.
Mhm.
Und in diesem dazu kommentierte Aaron. In der Folge sagt Tim beim Thema Avocado, dessen Telegramkanal sei teilweise bei einer Millionen Abonnentinnen gewesen. Diese laut Tim
auf mittlerweile fünfstellige Zahlen zusammengeschrumpften Kanäle waren allerdings noch nie im Millionenbereich angekommen und ihr Kanal ist grade an der Grenze zur Vierstelligkeit angekommen,
der von euch verlinkte Spiegelartikel schreibt von Peak 70.000 und das
sich mit meinen Erinnerungen. Andere wie Martin kommentieren, das ist schon mal irgendwie Peak über hunderttausend gewesen wären, aber eben nicht ähm.
Nicht über eine Million oder so. Und äh Attila Hildmann, das finde ich auch sehr, sehr, sehr spannend.
Also erstmal Entschuldigung, ich habe das so ein bisschen daher äh äh gesagt und habe mich dann in der Größenordnung äh irgendwie verlaufen, also Faktor zehn auf jeden Fall daneben, sorry.
Ähm immer noch schlimm genug, ne, aber ähm jetzt twitterte hier John Graf ähm.
Von Hildmann schreckt schon lange nicht mehr vor jeder noch so kruden These zurück und zwar
Twit hat er jetzt auf irgendeinem anderen Kanal, äh sagt er, folgende Namen wurden mir gesteckt als mögliche Verantwortliche.
Ole Reismann, dass der Ole Reismann ist Spiegel, na ja, wobei, nein, Bento, muss man sagen, ne, der der war bei Bento und jetzt
ist er wieder beim Spiegel, aber dieses, diese Kinderspiegel oder was das da war mit Bento. Aber eben seit bestimmt ist er seit zehn Jahren im Spiegelverlag. Christian Stöcker, ehemaliger Leiter der Spiegel Netzwelt, heute glaube ich irgendwo in
Hamburg Professor für Journalistik, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, damit also der Vorgänger von der Judith
Horchert, die wir ja auch schon zu Gast hatten in der Sendung. Konrad Lischka, Markus Beckedal und Andre Meister.
Aha. Jetzt wird einiges klar.
So, Konrad Lischka ist auch Journalist. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo der gerade ist,
oder ob der irgendwo fest ist. Er war auch mal Redakteur bei Spiegel Online Netzwelt,
und wo er jetzt ist, Staatskanzlei, weil bei der Staatsan Staatskanzlei Nordrhein-Westfalen und ist jetzt bei der Bär als Mann Stiftung.
Oder beim paritätischen Wolfgang. Ein, ein Mensch, der oft offenbar oft äh seinen Job gewechselt hat. Ähm.
Also das hat jetzt Attila Hildmann recherchiert und ich habe das natürlich andere geschickt und ich dachte, guck mal hier, jetzt hat er dich, ne?
Äh andere kommentierte einfach nur lakonisch auf Twitter auch. Attila Hildmann hat rausgefunden, wer Enorm es ist. Er hat gegoogelt und einen Blogpost von 2012 gefunden.
Und in diesem Blogpost tatsächlich, der ist auf Netzpolitik org, äh.
So so dieser Blogpost ist eine Buchrezension von Markus Beckedal,
die beginnt mit, heute ist das Taschenbuch, die Maske des Protests. Wer sie sind, was sie antreibt, was sie wollen. Der Dreispiegel Online-Redakteure Olaf Reismann, Christian Stöcker und Konrad Lischka, erschienen. So, damit haben wir jetzt
reist man Stöcker, Lischka und er andere Meister, äh der natürlich auch bei Netz Politik org ist, ist da nicht so schwer, den auch noch mit da rein zu mischen. Also die Google-Skills von Attila Hildmann, die sind schon wirklich Hammer, ne,
Das ist schon äh ist schon wirklich äh will man nicht meinen. Was die alles im Internet rausfinden können, ne?
Wahnsinn. Das ist Wahnsinn. Aber das ist ja auch ganz gut. Ich meine, dann haben wir jetzt auch mal unmittelbaren äh Zugriff auf dieses ganze Aloni-Bus. Wir haben uns ja auch immer schon gefragt, wer denn das nun eigentlich sein könnte gerade. Äh wer hätte es gedacht, dass das in unserem Hinterhof alles,
einfach stattfindet, ne? Ja. Muss Meister.
Ähm so, jetzt haben wir ähm.
Kommen wir mal langsam zu den Themen. Ein, ein Thema, was ja in letzter Zeit so, ich hatte das hier auch so ein bisschen gesagt, da sind so ein bisschen unklar. Das war dieser.
Revillangriff auf. Ein äh Dienstleister, der so eine Software für das Remote-Management,
von Servern ähm bereitstellt und zwar im Prinzip richtet sich diese Software so an, sage ich mal, Leute, die eben
Managed Server oder so etwas anbieten. Ja, also du du verdienst dein Geld quasi damit anderen Server zur Verfügung zu stellen und um diese Server irgendwie zu managen, nutzt du Casa.
Jetzt hat er diese äh eine Schwachstelle, die wurde von der Gruppe äh oder von einem der Revill Assoss jetzt quasi ausgenutzt und dann wurde.
Mit Hilfe dieser Management-Software auf sehr vielen Servern ähm diese revil ausgerollt.
Also im Prinzip alle ihre Kunden wurden mehr oder weniger zentral äh infiziert.
Und diese Kunden sind wiederum auch Dienstleister gewesen, was in Schweden zu dem Fall geführt hat, dass eine relativ große äh Supermarktkette namens Coop
äh zum Beispiel keine ähm Kartenzahlung mehr entgegennehmen konnte, weil quasi deren Payment-Dienstleister,
Software Server bei einem Dienstanbieter hatte, der die wiederum mit gemeldet hat und dann waren die eben alle verschlüsselt. So,
dann ähm war es auf einmal still, um um Review, die Webseite war offline und dann
also nee, ursprünglich wollten die 70 Millionen US-Dollar in Bitcoin haben, dann haben sie äh nah sich runterhandeln lassen auf 50. Die haben sie aber auch nicht bekommen. Dann sind sie auf einmal von der Bildfläche verschwunden.
Und dann irgendwann tauchte der Schlüssel auf.
Haben alle ein ähm einen Generalschlüssel bekommen. Allerdings sach mal mehrere Wochen später, was jetzt im Prinzip heißt, da wird eigentlich keiner mehr drauf gewartet haben. Die Wenigsten werden jetzt von diesem Schlüssel noch profitieren. Und es war quasi.
Die Frage, ähm was war da jetzt? Ja, also hat äh Russland äh gesagt, ey Leute,
reißt euch mal bitte zusammen, das war ein Schritt zu weit, so viel Ärger wollen wir nicht oder haben die USA äh angegriffen? Und tatsächlich ähm gibt jetzt ähm.
Das FBI bekannt, dass das äh FBI quasi Zugriff auf Server von Revil,
in Russland hatte und dabei in den Besitz des Generalschlüssels gelangt ist. Und diesen Schlüssel haben dir aber drei Wochen für sich behalten, um quasi ihre Operation da nicht zu gefährden.
Also die Situation war, die hatten sofort ein, das FBI hatte diesen Schlüssel.
Und hätte den veröffentlichen können und allen Opfern zur Verfügung stellen könnten, hat aber damit noch drei Wochen weiter gewartet.
Und die Abwägung ist warum? Ja unklar. Also weil sie ihre eigene Operation hier nicht
ähm äh in den in Gefahr bringen wollten, weil ein größerer Schlag gegen Revil geplant gewesen sei. Und man wollte die jetzt nicht vorwarnen. Dieser große Schlag ist aber nicht erfolgt,
weil Revill eben von der Bildfläche verschwunden ist. Bevor sie diesen großen Angriff machen konnten. Ähm.
Angriff Steiners ist nicht erfolgt.
Deswegen haben sie dann, genau, deswegen haben sie dann nach drei Wochen diese diesen Key schon hatten.
Den an Kasseya gegeben und hat den dann ja eben seinen seinen Kundinnen und Kunden oder seinen, also er hat den dann quasi zur Verfügung gestellt, den Opfern. Das ist natürlich ziemlich krass und ähm.
Jetzt müssen wir mal, also das hier, ne.
Ist ja jetzt mal ein klassischer Fall von. Ne? Hier wurde Angreifer, Infrastruktur kompromittiert. Ähm hier wurde.
Ähm mir wurden quasi deren Server angegriffen, ne?
Eben auch, wie ich auch immer sagte, ne, sowas wird langfristig geplant und damit haben die sicherlich nicht erst nach dem Angriff an äh angefangen, sondern wahrscheinlich waren die da schon länger dran. Aber das, womit sie das,
immer verteidigen und immer argumentieren, dass sie diese offensiven Fähigkeiten haben wollen, ist Schaden abzuwenden.
Und hier hat diese, hier hat dieses FBI Hackback gemacht, ja? Das, was immer mit Schaden abwenden, ähm, ja, begründet wird,
und genau das, was sie nicht getan haben, sobald sie die Möglichkeit hatten, war Schaden abzuwenden. Die haben quasi
bewusst und gezielt in Kauf genommen, dass gerade eine viele, ich weiß nicht, ob das zehntausende oder sogar hunderttausend Betroffene Unternehmen waren, aber auf jeden Fall sehr viel. Ich glaube, über die genaue Zahl war auch ähm.
Zwischenzeitlich sehr viel Unklarheit, ja. Und äh,
Ja, haben sie einfach nicht gemacht. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, vielen Dank. So super toller Hackbag. Ne, also ich meine.
Und Back ist wirklich also,
Auch frech, also ich meine, das ist halt auch wirklich jetzt die Frage, was ist eigentlich so ihr Selbstverständnis, in dem Fall des FBIs?
Ja, wem sie jetzt hier eigentlich eine Dienstleistung anbieten. Weil man wird ja als einfacher erstmal erwarten,
ne? Das ähm und das,
Ei selbst ist jetzt vielleicht gar nicht so das beste Beispiel. Ich denke halt jetzt grade so eher in Richtung BSI, ne. Man würde sich jetzt mal so vorstellen, äh eine ähnliche Situation läge beim BSI vor eine andere
ähm Gruppe des äh der Regierung würde dann sozusagen dem BSI zwar diesen Kiel geben, aber sagen, ja, halt mal noch
Unterm Teppich, weil wir wollen jetzt hier noch irgendwie so eine Aktion machen mit einem von unserem ich weiß nicht, einhundert
53 verschiedenen Cyberorganisationen, die sich äh Deutschland und Europa mittlerweile zugelegt haben, wo keiner genau weiß, wer jetzt eigentlich wofür zuständig ist und,
Damit kann dann eben die eigentliche Aufgabe dieses dieser Behörde und jetzt würde ich das mal unterstellen, dass auch,
Das FBI ja an sowas ein Interesse haben sollte, nämlich Schutz der eigenen Wirtschaft, ja, äh nicht vorgenommen werden. Das ist schon echt hardcore.
Ist krass, oder?
Aber ja wundert wundert mich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, ne? Ich meine, das ist ja das, dass die nicht lauter argumentieren und nicht in in in den Interessen nach den Interessen vorgehen, die sie vorschieben, das ist ja genau das, was ich immer ähm.
Einfach die falsche Motivation, ne. Die werden dann sozusagen an ihrer Kriminalitätsaufklärung gemessen,
Ja, so wie viel Erfolg hattet ihr denn jetzt hier mit eurem ganzen Cyberkram, wo wir jetzt so viele Millionen reingesteckt haben? Ja und dann kriegt das eben Priorität.
Und wenn's Priorität hat, dann malte andere Sachen, keine Priorität.
Ja. Ja, übrigens, da reiht sich ja auch sehr schön unser nächstes Thema ein. Wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, dass das.
Bundeskriminalamt sich äh die Software Pegasus gekauft hat, die mit äh Hilfe von Zero Days in ähm Apple Produkten ähm auf Geräte,
angebracht wird, die gegen.
Menschenrechtsaktivisten, Oppositionelle, Journalistinnen weltweit ähm eingesetzt wird, die in der Ermordung von Jamal Khashoggi eine Rolle gespielt hat,
und siehe nun wirklich von einem Unternehmen ist, mit dem man in keiner Weise äh zusammenarbeiten möchte, ähm das hat sich das BKA äh gekauft,
und die äh GF, also Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte hat nun beim Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten Ulrich Kälber Beschwerde gegen deren Einsatz,
eingereicht,
Und da sagt der Verfahrenskoordinator David Werdermann durch den Einsatz des Trojaners, erhält ein privates ausländisches Unternehmen, das mutmaßlich im Auftrag autoritärer Staaten auch Journalistinnen und Menschenrechtlerinnen aus Schwedt Zugriff auf hochsensible Daten
der Bürgerinnen in Deutschland. Das ist natürlich korrekt.
Da muss man natürlich sagen, ne, dass äh äh dass das eben das eines der entscheidenden Argumente dieses Setups ist, ne, die hacken ja für dich und äh geben dir nicht quasi
den Quercode und die Schwachstelle, äh sondern die bieten dir quasi ein Interface, wo du nur eine Telefonnummer eingibst und dann wird die kompromittiert. Ähm.
Denke, dass es sehr sinnvoll hier äh auf diesem Wege vorzugehen, weil auf der ethisch moralischen Schiene, was das eigentlich bedeutet, ähm da braucht man ja leider der Bundesrepublik Deutschland nicht mehr zu kommen.
Das hat auf jeden Fall bisher nicht funktioniert.
So, dann haben wir äh hatten wir darüber gesprochen, dass ja die CDU äh die Lilit Widmann.
Angezeigt hatte oder einen Strafantrag gegen sie gestellt hatte, weil sie angeblich äh deren App gehackt hätte.
Und
jetzt äh hat sie ein bisschen darüber äh geschrieben, dass hier diese Schwachstelle damals dem BSI und der,
CDU gemeldet hat und der Datenschutzbeauftragten und das ähm sie dann nach § 22 ABC STGB auch bekannt als der Hacker Paragraph äh angezeigt wurde. Ähm,
zweitausendsieben,
wurde dieser Hacker Paragraph eingeführt von der CDU als Regierungspartei gemeinsam mit der SPD. Damals mit sehr großen Widerstand, weil der eben das Ausspähen von Daten und vor allem das
aus das Vorbereiten des Ausspähens und Abfangen von Daten unter Strafe stellt und damit quasi ähm.
Jede, jeden Besitz von Software, die auch zum Hecken geeignet ist, potenziell strafbar macht
Ja, wir haben das hat nach meiner Kenntnis bisher noch keine Anwendung gefunden. Dieser vorbereiten, ja, aber theoretisch kann ich sagen, jeder Computer, den ich besitze, äh den könnte man auf jeden Fall als ähm Beweismittel,
dafür sehen, dass ich das Ausspähen von Daten zumindest vorbereitet habe.
Weil das ja auch etwas ist, was ich äh eben täglich beruflich tue. Nun ja, jetzt äh hat sie ähm.
Hat die CDU quasi als als Anlass genommen, dass äh irgendjemand,
ein ein Link äh vertwittert hätte und zwar PacePint com CDU Connect unter dem sich angeblich äh diese Inhalte befunden hätten. Aber also irgendwelche geliebten Inhalte.
Und ähm jetzt ist es so, bei Pace bin kannst du nach meiner Kenntnis und auch nach äh Nachkenntnis von Lid Wittmann nicht,
den Link benennen ja, sondern du machst einfach einen neuen auf und dann kommt eine zufällige Zeichenfolge oder eine,
quasi eine hochzählende Hexedezimale, Zeichenfolge, was auch immer, auf jeden Fall nicht, dass du sagen kannst, ich möchte hier mal bitte URL haben, so dass unter Pacebin dot com Slash äh CDU-Connect äh wahrscheinlich niemals etwas lag. Ähm.
Jedenfalls langer Rede kurzer Sinn. Dieses Verfahren wurde dann jetzt am Ende eingestellt, weil die.
Ähm Staatsanwaltschaft feststellt,
ähm damit hier eine ähm damit hier irgendwie Hacking stattgefunden hätte.
Hätte eben eine Überwindung von Sicherheitsmerkmalen oder einer Zugangssicherung ähm stattfinden müssen,
Und die ähm die Staatsanwaltschaft schreibt, die Ermittlungen haben ergeben, dass der Zugriff auf die von der CDU-Connect-App gespeicherten Daten aufgrund einer Sicherheitslücke der App,
möglich war. Eine Überwindung von Sicherheitsmerkmalen oder einer Zugangssicherung war aufgrund der Sicherheitslücke gerade nicht notwendig. Eine Veröffentlichung der gespeicherten Daten konnte auch nicht festgestellt werden und damit,
ist eine weitere Strafverfolgung,
erfolgsversprechend, mit anderen Worten, die sagen, ihr wurdet gar nicht gehackt, ihr hättet die Daten frei im Netz und deswegen ähm stellen wir jetzt dieses Verfahren ein. Was? Eine sehr schöne ähm.
Ein sehr schöner äh Ausgang äh dieser Geschichte ist.
Ja, da ist man auch schon mal beruhigt, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft überhaupt in der Lage ist zu einer Feststellung zu kommen.
Ehrlich gesagt, also ich bin mir mal nicht so sicher, ob die äh ob die Staatsanwaltschaft wirklich ähm dazu gekommen ist. Ähm.
Gekommen wurde.
Gekommen wurde, ja? Äh ob da nicht eventuell der gute Herr Hennewick gesehen hat, dass er seine christliche Union da ähm
mal gerade richtig tief in die Scheiße gefahren hat und vielleicht dich einfach wirklich bei der Staatsanwaltschaft
gebettelt hat und gesagt hat, lasst euch bitte irgendetwas einfallen, damit diese Kuh vom Eis ist. Ähm wir möchten.
Dass das einfach nicht mehr weiter medial begleitet haben.
Ja, kann schon sein, aber Präzedenz ist präzidenz, ne, also das ist natürlich jetzt auf jeden Fall mal äh aufgeschrieben, dass sowas auch sein kann und daran können sie sich schon mal.
Ja, aber natürlich, also ich meine, das ist halt hier eine, das ist ja hier eine eine Entscheidung der Staatsanwaltschaft, die ist jetzt kein Präzedenz, kannst du jetzt nicht sagen, beim nächsten Mal, Entschuldigung, die Staatsanwaltschaft so und so hat auch mal irgendwie festgestellt, dass
aussichtslos ist, ne? Also äh ein Urteil wäre ein Urteil wäre schon präzedenziger. Aber ja, ähm ist auf jeden Fall sollte jetzt,
hoffentlich jeder davon gelernt haben, was man dafür, was man davon hat, wenn man jemanden, der Sicherheitslücken meldet, eben nachher,
versucht, strafrechtlich zu belangen. Gibt es übrigens noch einen anderen Fall, der gerade ähm recht spannend ist.
Ähm und zwar gab es da eine fällt mir jetzt gerade eher spontan ein, so eine ähm Sicherheitslücke bei,
wo auch mehr oder weniger die Daten relativ öffentlich zugänglich waren. Und zwar war das bei äh,
Modern Solution, der Modern Solution GmbH und Co KG.
Die irgendwie eine ähm App bereitgestellt haben, ja und diese App ähm hat ähm,
hat direkt auf eine SQL-Datenbank zugegriffen,
Also die hat da, da gab's jetzt nicht eine API mit irgendwelchen äh ne, mit irgendwelchen Tokens und Rechten auf das oder jenes zuzugreifen, sondern es gab ähm,
Es gab einfach quasi der direkt auf die SQL-Datenbank äh zugegriffen und alle in der App hatten natürlich einfach die gleichen,
Nutzerdaten. Das heißt in der App selber, die du da hattest, standen quasi die die ähm SQL,
Daten, mit denen du auf die gesamte Datenbank zugreifen konntest und diese Datenbank in dieser Datenbank waren aber viele unterschiedliche Kunden,
von unterschiedlichen Kunden dieses Unternehmens drin. Zum Beispiel Kaufland Otto, Check 4zwanzigund oder Idealo und somit insgesamt 700.000 Endkunden.
Und davon wurden, konnte man Transaktionen seit Sommer zwanzig achtzehn einsehen im Juli zwanzig1undzwanzig. Ja und äh ähm.
Ja, was willst du dazu sagen? Also dadurch, dass das halt quasi, ne, wenn du jetzt mit den Zugangsdaten, mit denen Otto darauf zugegriffen hat, konnten die jetzt quasi bei Idealo
oder hätten sie bei Idealo einfach löschen können, wie sie wollen. Und da die Zugangsdaten einfach in der App drin standen, braucht es sie dir nur kurz die App anzuschauen und wusstest
wieder zugegriffen wird, ne? Diese Schwachstelle wurde dann von jemandem gefunden.
Der sie ähm gemeldet hat bei dem Unternehmen und dann,
Ja, das war wahrscheinlich nichts so elegant, ähm sehr früh,
darauf hingewirkt hat, dass das auch veröffentlicht wird. Und zwar,
wurde das früher veröffentlicht als diese Datenbank offline war. Ähm das hat jetzt leider dazu geführt, ähm dass,
Unternehmen auch hier gegen diesen ähm,
ohne jede bösartige, also mit reinem Gewissen und ohne Schädigungsabsicht vorgehenden äh Entwickler ähm
Eine Strafanzeige erstattet hat und der hatte jetzt auch eine Hausdurchsuchung. Ja, das ist also nicht ganz so äh schön und zumal der in diesem Bereich der IT,
ähm auch ähm tätig ist, äh ist das natürlich jetzt auch nicht nicht so ähm nicht so lustig, ja? Ähm.
Für ihn. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie als Programmierer ähm tätig bist und du hast auf einmal irgendwie, ne, ein Verfahren wegen Ausspähen von Daten, also genau, auch hier zweihundertzwei. Ähm,
am Hals deine Geräte sind beschlagnahmt, das ist natürlich schon relativ übel. Ähm.
An dieser Stelle deshalb noch mal so ein bisschen der Hinweis, also wenn's geht,
Und wenn ihr solche Sachen zum ersten Mal macht, äh macht euch bitte vielleicht besser darüber,
oder holt euch mal Rat, was ein kluges Vorgehen ist und was nicht. Ähm in diesem Fall,
ich weiß nicht, ob's inhaltlich für das Verfahren eine Rolle spielt, weil ja das es wird ja das Ausspielen von Daten vorgeworfen, das wird man vermutlich.
Glaube ich nicht, dass derjenige, der hier diese Schwachstelle gefunden gefunden und gemeldet hat, ähm jetzt am Ende gestraft wird,
bestraft werden wird, aber es ist natürlich trotzdem ähm ein äh ein Problem
Ja ähm wenn man in einem solchen Verfahren landet, genauso wie es jetzt für die Lilith Widmann vielleicht halbwegs lustig war, ähm,
Aber trotzdem mit mit Stress und,
potentiell vielen Problemen und Kosten verbunden war. Insofern wir ähm helfen da ja als CCC sehr, sehr regelmäßig bei solchen Sachen und ähm.
Lieber einmal zu oft fragen, als ähm einmal zu wenig.
Denke oder hoffe, dass man hier so etwas hätte vermeiden können, äh sehr häufig machen wir das auch so, dass wir einfach die Meldung im Namen von anderen,
machen, also einfach sagen, hier hallo, Chaos, Computerclub. Folgendes sollen wir Ihnen weiterreichen, ja, einfach um ähm so eine, so, so blöde Reaktionen,
ähm zu verhindern.
Hoffen wir also mal, dass dass dieses äh dass dieser Fall auch aufgeklärt wird und es hier nicht zu irgendwelchen ähm.
Strafmaßnahmen gegenüber Leuten kommt, die eine Schwachstelle gemeldet haben.
Oder halt die Proxis. Ich meine, gerade jetzt im Film, alles ist eins, außer der Null, wo du ja dann auch nochmal die alte Geschichte da mit Steffen äh auch nochmal kurz beleuchtet.
Der dann quasi auch in die Öffentlichkeit ging, als CCC für andere Hacker, die diesen NASA-Heck gemacht haben und als man dann die Behörden aufgeklärt hat, na ja, dann führte es langfristig dazu, dass er dann in Frankreich erstmal einen,
wurde, obwohl er da irgendwie technisch überhaupt nichts mit zu tun hatte und auch gar nicht die Fähigkeit gehabt hatte, da in irgendeiner Form was zu machen. Ja, mittlerweile äh.
Hilft aber das Schutzschild an der Stelle dann schon äh ein bisschen.
Weil sich das ja dann doch äh rumgesprochen hat, dass nicht unbedingt immer die Leute, die als erstes was dazu sagen, auch automatisch die Schuldigen sind.
Ja, kann ich auch nochmal übrigens an der Stelle an den.
Vortrag von Thorsten und mir erinnern, du kannst alles hacken, du darfst dich noch nicht erwischen lassen. Es ist immer klug, ähm egal in welchem,
Absicht man unterwegs ist äh,
es zu vermeiden, dass Beweis äh äh oder Beweise anfallen, die einem zur Last gelegt werden können. Insbesondere wenn man sich in einem Bereich bewegt, wo äh die meisten Menschen mit einer
himmelschreienden Inkompetenz gesegnet sind und ähm man halt wirklich auch hoffen muss,
bei äh Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft überhaupt in kompetenten Bereichen zu landen, die eine schnelle und adäquate Einschätzung,
des Sachverhaltes zu liefern in der Lage sind. Und gerade bei diesem Modern Solution-Ding muss man einfach mal sagen äh,
Das war ja schon öffentlich dokumentiert in Blogpost und in Zeitungsartikeln äh oder in Magazinartikeln auf Spiegel Online, dass hier eine Meldung stattgefunden hat und nicht etwa irgendjemand diese Daten jetzt äh äh geklaut hat oder sowas.
Mit der Kompetenz äh ist es ja auch in anderen Kreisen nicht so weit äh her. Es gibt ja viele Leute, die bewegen sich so durch das Internet und nehmen kein Blatt vor den Mund und äh machen das auch mit ihrer eigenen Identität
Das hat dann leider auch äh nicht unbedingt dazu geführt, dass äh sofort Maßnahmen dagegen äh,
ergriffen wurden. Ich rede natürlich jetzt von dieser Querdenkerszene,
ein sehr unrühmliches ähm ja was sehr unrühmlich äh Konsequenzen jetzt hatte. Ich war ein bisschen unterwegs, hab's nur so am äh Rande mitbekommen, aber es gab ja so einen Attentat.
Auf ein völlig unbeteiligten Tankstellen, Bediensteten, junger Mann, der dann von irgend so einem Querdenker auf,
Grund des Hinweises, er solle doch mal eine Maske anziehen gleich 'ne Knarre gezogen hat und ihn erschossen hat.
Also ich vielleicht kurz ergänzend, wenn ich das verstehe, ist der nach Hause gegangen, hat seine Knarre geholt und hat ihn dann erschossen. Also ich glaube, Attentat ist hier vielleicht der falsche Begriff, das war einfach ein Mord, ne?
Habe ich Attentat gesagt?
Ja aber ja.
Ja, gut, also Mord, gar keine Frage. Ähm.
Und auf einmal kann dann auch Facebook mal reagieren und stellt fest, so, oh, diese Leute, die hier schon seit äh über einem Jahr frei drehen, die könnte man ja dann doch vielleicht mal ein bisschen sanktionieren und hat jetzt zahlreiche,
Querdenker Kanäle äh vom Netz hätte ich fast gesagt, von aus ihrem Netz genommen.
Mit anderen Worten, die haben jetzt irgendwie diese, diesen Ballweg und äh andere Wahnsinnige aus dieser ganzen Querdenker äh Szene äh endlich mal die Konten dicht gemacht und die entsprechenden Gruppen gemacht. Das betrifft sie allerdings nur Facebook.
Und nicht WhatsApp.
Also ähm wenn man sich so richtig so sicher äh inwiefern sie da noch unter Scheidung machen, aber ist natürlich auf jeden Fall schon mal zu begrüßen, dass hier überhaupt was passiert, auch wenn das in gewisser Hinsicht viel zu spät kommt.
Ja und was und also Querdenker, ne. Ähm,
in dieser Woche, also dieser Mord ist ja jetzt ein paar Tage her und in dieser Woche kommt dann hier Wolfgang Kubicki, ja,
erklärt großspurig, er wäre ja während des Lockdowns illegal in Kneipen gewesen, weil er von seinem Recht auf autonomes Handeln Gebrauch gemacht habe.
Es gibt ein CDU Werbespot in der,
ähm ach so, hier Kneipe, Kubicki ist ja offenbar ein ähm Freund der Kneipe, ja. Äh erklärt dann noch,
ähm in seiner Stammkneipe würde man ähm Karl Lauterbach als Spacken bezeichnen, ja. Karl Lauterbach, sage ich mal, die eines der primären Hassobjekte neben ähm ähm,
Christian Drosten im, im Rahmen dieser Pandemiebekämpfung, also eines der eine, eine der Personen, die wirklich,
ernsthaft von diesen Querdenkerspinnern bedroht werden, auf die Besh dann dieser dieser bemitleidenswerte Trinker-Kubbicki auch noch ein, ja? Und dann gibt's hier irgendwie diesen.
Das war vor zwei Wochen oder so. Ähm gab's da irgendwie so ein ähm Wahlkampfsituation von ähm Armin Laschet,
wo dann irgendwie so ein Querdenker, der sich für ein Opfer des Holocausts 2 Punkt 0 hält,
unterbrochen wurde und dann irgendwie seinen Realitätsverlust zur zur äh zum Besten gegeben hat,
Jetzt wirbt die CDU damit, dass sie ja sogar ein äh ähm,
ein offenes Ohr für diejenigen mit einer kritischen Haltung hätte, ja? Die stellen sich jetzt noch positiv da, dass sie sich mit so einem wahnsinnigen Seuchenfreund auseinandersetzen.
Und der Kubicki berühmt sich damit, äh was weiß ich, sich gegen sich gegen, ne, die Schutzmaßnahmen ähm,
äh zur Wehr gesetzt zu haben. Und das ist natürlich, das funktioniert das passiert gerade mit Kalkül. Und es ist zum Kotzen, wenn derartige,
ähm Gruppierungen hier jetzt auch noch nach aller Mühe von diesen Parteien hochführt und Normalisiert werden. So, wir haben jetzt gesehen, wohin die Scheiße führt und es war jetzt auch.
Absehbar, dass ähm dass es irgendeinen verwirrten,
durchgeknallten Menschen da draußen so weit treiben würde, dass er eine Gewalttat begeht, ja? Und sei es jemand in der Tanke zu erschießen, weil er gesagt hat, wenn ein Bier kaufen willst, muss dir eine Maske anziehen.
So weit sind wir gekommen. Und das liegt daran, dass das diese,
diese CDU und diese CSU und diese FDP, ich mein die FDP kannst du eh vergessen, Kubicki ohnehin, ne?
Dass die diesen gesellschaftlichen Strömungen auch noch in den Arsch kriechen, statt ihnen entschieden entgegen zu treten,
Ja, ich hatte gerade heute noch eine äh kurzes kurzen Austausch mit einer Person.
Äh die auch irgendwie unzufrieden damit war, dass ich kategorisch sage, ich will mit Impfgegnern nichts zu tun haben, ja? Und ich merkte schon, ah, das Thema interessiert dich mit anderen Worten. Du bist
Impfgegner, ja? Und da musste ich mir auch noch irgendwie,
dann kannst du dir solche Sätze anhören wie, ich glaube nicht an Medienstatistiken und so weiter. Ich glaube, das, was ich erlebe und sehe und das hat Hand und Fuß. Und deswegen kann kann sich jeder entscheiden, ob er sich impfen lassen möchte oder nicht. Und du, lieber Linus, bist jetzt intolerant,
nichts mit Menschen zu tun haben möchtest, die in einer tödlichen Pandemie auf eine Impfung verzichten,
So, warum möchte ich mit diesen Menschen nichts zu tun haben? Erstens, weil ich davon ausgehe, dass die auch in anderen Themenbereichen nicht zu besonders ähm sagen wir mal äh weitreichenden oder inspirierenden Ansichten in der Lage sind,
Äh zweitens, weil ich ähm,
evolutionär hoffe auf der Seite der Gewinner zu sein und mich sehr freue, wenn wir hier äh David ein bisschen äh walten lassen können.
Aber drittens, dass dass ich auch ganz klar denke, dass diese Menschen klar damit konfrontiert werden müssen, dass sie in einer völligen irrsinnigen Wahrnehmungswelt sind.
Und.
Dann hast du so ein Laschet, der dann irgendwie ernsthaft damit auch noch bürgernäher ausdrücken will, dass er sich von denen mit zwanzig Zentimeter Abstand ins Gesicht schreien lässt.
Also ey und so reagieren wir auf jedes gesellschaftliche Gift,
dir die scheiß Faschisten von der AfD an. Denen tritt auch keiner äh entschieden entgegen und sagt, nein, ihr seid einfach nur blöde Faschisten, Punkt.
Hatte mich in der letzten Sendung schon darüber beschwert, dass der, dass hier Lindner, okay, von Lindner brauchst du auch nichts zu erwarten, ne? Dass der dann auch noch irgendwie der Weide recht gibt, äh weil weil,
weil sie irgendeinen Stuss redet, weil weder irgendeine Studie ihr nicht passt, weil dabei rauskommt, dass sie einfach nur Scheiße redet. Und ich ich möchte wirklich wieder in einer Welt leben.
In der Verstand.
Wissenschaft noch etwas wert sind. Und das sehe ich wirklich in zwei Hinsichten hier. Da finde ich solche Bullshit-Bingostudien genauso tragisch,
wie ähm weil weil die die tragen ja nur dazu bei, dass die Leute in arg wohnen gegenüber der Wissenschaft entwickeln,
Die tragen ja nur dazu bei, dass man sagt, na ja, pass auf, dann müssen wir halt doch für Wissenschaftsverlage Unmengen an Geld bezahlen, weil die wenigstens halbwegs durch ihr Peer-Review, was alle kostenlos leisten, irgendwie halbwegs Qualität in die Wissenschaft einbringen,
Ja, aber es ist zum verrückt werden, wie wie fern.
Von Tatsachen und Realität und gesichertem Wissen argumentiert wird, in allen möglichen Bereichen und wie wir
alle bereit sind, das zu tolerieren. Statt einfach mal eine Ohrfeige nach der anderen zu verteilen und klar zu sagen, pass auf, das, was du hier redest, ist einfach nur Unsinn und deswegen brauchen wir da auch nicht mehr weiter drüber zu reden, weil uns das nicht weiter bringt.
Und jetzt haben wir Tote. Geil.
Ciao. Ich meine, du hast Recht und ähm jetzt haben wir Tote und ich befürchte sogar, das wird nicht sehr viel bringen.
Weißt du, was sie jetzt nämlich hast? Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kann ich dir schon die Kommentare schreiben.
Ja, die kann ich mir selber schreiben, könnte euch auch sparen. Dass jetzt irgendwelche Leute kommen. Ich bin äh kritischer Geist und ich glaube, eine Impfung ist äh für mein Chakra nicht gut. Und äh deswegen möchte ich nicht von dir mit Mördern verglichen werden. Äh
ja, schreibt in Kommentar bitte woanders. Schreibt in deine Telegram-Gruppe oder sowas. Echt, das ist, es ist einfach so was
Dummheit kommt von Dummheit. Und deswegen muss man Dummheit entgegentreten, sonst kriegt man einfach nur noch mehr Dummheit. Und dass am Ende dann irgendwelche ganz dummen Vollidioten, irgendwelche geplagten
Seelen so eine Scheiße dann auch noch als als ein Primärkonflikt der Gesellschaft wahrnehmen äh in in dessen Kontext sie meinen, töten zu müssen. Darüber muss man sich eben Gedanken machen, wenn man, wenn man völligen,
Unsinn redet, wie übrigens auch, ähm,
andere menschenverachtende Ideologien, die was weiß ich, Frauen oder Nationalitäten als minderwertig empfinden oder sonst was.
Ich wäre ja schon ganz froh, wenn wir zumindest äh unsere Polizei mal ähm so äh in in die Situation bringen könnten, dagegen auch äh automatisch irgendwas äh,
zu unternehmen. Ja, also die die Automatismen fehlen mir an der Stelle auch schon. Also bei der Politik kann man sich jetzt natürlich auch groß äh beklagen, haben wir jetzt im Prinzip auch gerade getan.
Aber ähm mich macht es äh immer besonders unruhig, dass man eben auch einfach gar nicht davon ausgehen kann, dass dass dieses Verhalten,
ähm bei der Exekutive.
Präsent ist. Ja, wir haben das gesehen mit diesen ganzen Querdenker Demos, wie viele Monate hat das gedauert, bis er überhaupt mal irgendeinen nennenswerte Reaktion gezeigt wurde, während
parallel äh eigentlich immer die die Gegendemos mit Wasserwerfern zusammengesprüht wurden.
So und das ist das ist so diese diese Automatik, so dieses das ist das ist irgendwie Bild in hat man so äh das Gefühl, ne. Klar, natürlich äh
können die sich dann darauf zurückziehen und sagen, das war die Anweisung hier und der Modus da und Gefahrenverzug und keine Ahnung, aber man merkt halt auch einfach,
wie so ein Weltbild an der Stelle äh aktiviert wird, dass immer sagt so, hier der normale Spießbürger, der kann ja irgendwie überhaupt nicht gefährlich sein.
Ist ja irgendwie immer die Masse. So, da kann man ja jetzt nicht irgendwie einfach mal überzogen reagieren. Aber so die aufgeklärten, sogenannten Linken, ja, die also,
Wie du das jetzt auch gerade getan hast, oft auch,
nicht immer, ja, aber oft eben aus so einer Grundinformierten Haltung heraus einfach äh grundlegende Probleme,
ansprechen. Die sind dann automatisch immer schon so 'ne Zielscheibe und das find ich wirklich verstörend. Und das hat natürlich auch was damit zu tun, was,
der,
vorherrschende Gedanke in der Gesellschaft ist, dass denken die sich ja auch nicht einfach so aus. Mal jetzt abgesehen von rechter Unterwanderung bei der Polizei, die es mit Sicherheit äh
auch gibt, ja, also die teilweise schon dann vielleicht auch systematisch ist und wo du irgendwie Netzwerke hast und dann haben wir ja auch schon über diese ganzen.
Bei der Polizei hier auch schon oft,
aus. Hauptproblem ist es, das ist einfach in der Gesellschaft selber noch nicht genug Überzeugung gibt, da etwas gegen
tun, zu müssen, dagegen vorgehen zu müssen und es sind auch viele Tabumechanismen, über die Jahrzehnte weggefallen.
Es durchaus mal gab nach dem Krieg. Ich kenne das ja auch selber noch, siebziger, achtziger Jahre. Da wäre viel von dem nie,
nicht möglich gewesen. Ich will auch nicht, alles war gut und alles war super, wissen auch, dass da auch noch viel Altnazis irgendwie in den Strukturen drin hingen, aber die Reaktion ähm der Gesellschaft war,
anders und das hat äh nachgelassen und wir sind jetzt so ein bisschen in der Problematik, dass wenn wir das jetzt halt so weiterlaufen lassen, dass das noch schlimmer werden könnte.
Gut, lass uns über schöne Sachen reden, lass uns über digitale Führerscheine reden. Ist doch auch was Tolles, oder?
Andi Scheuer, Andy Scheuer, gibt uns noch einen mit auf den letzten Metern, hoffentlich, ey. Digitaler Führerschein.
Das Jahr ist erstmal nichts Schlimmes.
Es ist erstmal nichts Schlimmes. Es ist äh von dem es tatsächlich, wir haben auch eine Mail bekommen, dass sie sagt, nee, da habe ich noch nie von gehört. Warum habt ihr das nicht behandelt? Ähm.
Lese da jetzt nur ja soll kommen. Ist aber jetzt noch nicht so wirklich klar, äh wie genau das äh,
stattfinden soll, ja? Also
soll im Rahmen einer App die ID Wallet heißt, also digitale Brieftasche werden, die irgendwie vom Kraftfahrtbundesamt mit der Bundesdruckerei entwickelt wird
und äh dann eben auf Basis der Zentralen des äh auf Basis des zentralen Registers KBRA ausgestellt werden soll. Ähm und dann kann man,
potentiell mit diesem digitalen Führerschein äh zum Beispiel äh seine Fahr,
Befähigung beim Auto mieten, ähm schon mal remote äh unter Beweis stellen.
Äh sonstige Dinge. Ich würde an dieser Stelle eher ähm eine eine Meterperspektive einnehmen. Ja, wir haben, was grundsätzlich,
die Fälschbarkeit von Dingen angeht, ja? Sei das bei Geld, sei das bei Pässen, bei ähm
Ausweisen bei äh Impfbescheinigungen oder was auch immer man irgendwie so äh quasi als Beweis haben möchte.
Ähm in der analogen Welt halt so diesen Aspekt der
wir versuchen irgendwie durch kunstvolle Fertigungsverfahren die Fälschung zu erschweren.
Ne? Und ich habe das, glaube ich, schon öfter mal erzählt, dass ich mal auf der oder der Security Printers Konferenz war. Das ist also quasi eine die Konferenz derer, die so diese ganzen Verfahren
machen, also die irgendwie schwer fälschbare Papiere herstellen nach geheimen Rezepten, auf die dann Geld gedruckt wird. Ne, und irgendwelche.
Maschinenbauen für besondere Hologramme und die dann immer davon ausgehen, dass dadurch, dass ihr Fertigungsprozess kompliziert ist, es niemand anderem gelingen würde, den.
Nachzugestalten, ja? Und das ist natürlich so eine äh eine Annahme, die nie lange hält. Und.
Es ist so, dass wir mit den Mitteln der Kryptographie.
Tatsächlich digitale Sachverhalte signieren können und sie damit tatsächlich gegen Fälschung.
Wirksam schützen können. Also, sagen wir mal, eine digitale Signatur mit einem ordentlichen Algorithmus zu knacken und zu fälschen, ist,
quasi so schwer und so unmöglich, dass dem gegenüber jeder physikalische Fälschungsprozess Sport billig erscheint
Und deswegen sind natürlich digitale Signaturen etwas, was man erstens seit vielen Jahrzehnten hat und was man jetzt auch tatsächlich anwenden könnte.
So, nach der Pläne der EU soll es zum Beispiel Personalausweis, Führerschein, Diplome und andere wichtige Dokumente deines Lebens.
Zukünftig erfassen, dass du die Digitalrechtsgültig nachweisbar machst. Und dafür braucht man nicht viel, dafür braucht einigt man sich auf ein Format, da vereinigt man sich auf CAs, die man akzeptiert und am Ende ist das nicht,
viel komplizierter als ähm,
digitale Impfnachweist, den man ja auch hinbekommen hat. Dieser Bereich allerdings, weil man erkennt, dass,
digitale Identitäten etwas sind, was garantiert in Zukunft ähm eine große Rolle spielen will, ist natürlich jetzt äh oder eine große Rolle spielen wird.
Ist jetzt von allen möglichen Technologieanbieterinnen umkämpft, ne. Im Kleinen und im Großen. Äh wir haben bereits ähm
seit längerer Zeit von Google und Facebook die Initiativen quasi das Single Sign on zum Internet zu werden, ne? Melde dich einfach mit Google bei dem nächsten Service an oder wir haben,
hier zum Beispiel diese Bestrebungen mit dem digitalen äh Impfausweis, der natürlich auch von denjenigen, die den entwickeln, die halt denken natürlich daran, als nächstes Personalausweise, Führerschein oder sonstiges umzusetzen. Ähm,
interessante Aspekt ist, welche Technologie setzt sich am Ende durch,
und welche Privatsphäre Implikationen hat sie, ne? Baut man das auf eine Weise, die äh cool ist oder nicht? Baut man das auf eine Weise, die ohne Blockchain funktioniert oder auf eine Weise mit Blockchain? Und da ist,
jetzt zumindest konnte ich für diesen digitalen Führerschein noch nicht äh genug,
Informationen finden, um das jetzt äh abschließend technisch zu beurteilen. Aber was auf jeden Fall gerade ein Problem ist,
dass verschiedene Anbieterinnen und verschiedene Standards gerade versuchen, in Konkurrenz zu treten, um am Ende ähm,
alles.
Werden zu können, ne? Und und um quasi irgendwann die Identitätsprovider oder der Identitätsprovider zu werden. Das ist das, was wir da jetzt grade feststellen und ich bin mal gespannt, wie viele ähm.
Wie viele Fehl, wie viele Projektfails ist jetzt da braucht und wie gut wir das am Ende umgesetzt kriegen, weil ohne ohne Zweifel, wenn man's ordentlich machen würde, mit Self-Soverant Identitys und so könnte man hier echt coole Sachen bauen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall äh richtig. Ich hatte das mal als Beispiel genannt, ne, dass man ähm also ein einfaches Beispiel äh,
muss jemandem gegenüber nachweisen, dass du Auto fahren darfst, ja? Und dann würdest du vielleicht einfach nur diese Befähigung nachweisen
und nicht unbedingt auch noch dein Geburtsdatum dazugeben oder deine Adresse, weil das vielleicht in dem Kontext keine Rolle spielt. Und äh ne, wenn jetzt dein
auf dem Führerschein steht ja auch glaube ich gar keine Adresse, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ne? Und das
könnte man quasi zu so einem zu seinem Gesamtiitätsding machen, wo da eben gesagt wird, okay, jetzt brauche ich mal deine Adresse. Jetzt brauche ich mal deine Kreditkartennummer. Jetzt brauche ich mal deine Befugnis, ein Auto zu steuern. Jetzt brauche ich mal deine Befugnis, ein Flugzeug zu fliegen. Und das alles kann man sehr schön bauen.
Man kann es aber auch total schrottig bauen. Und,
da bin ich halt jetzt bei etwas, was Andi Scheuer auf den Weg gebracht hat, ähm erstmal noch ähm sagen wir mal äh gehalten vorsichtig.
Zurückhalten bist du ja skeptisch.
Zurückhaltend.
Warum kann ich das so gut verstehen? Ich meine, ich schaue mir jetzt hier irgendwie diese Meldung an und dann wird dann irgendwie auch,
sofort, ja, also digitaler Führerschein, ja, okay, gut, warum nicht alle Ausweise irgendwie auch mal digital?
Habe ich jetzt erstmal nix äh gegen, hat ja auch Vorteile so, weil wie viel Probleme hat man immer irgendwas zu belegen und dann muss man immer irgendwie scans von irgendwelchen Plastikkarten irgendwo hinschicken und die irgendwie
äh in so so merkwürdigen Online-Videoprozeduren in die Kamera reinwackeln, damit irgendwie Wasserzeichen von irgendwelchen
online ausgelesen werden können, das ist auch irgendwie absurd, ja? Das irgendwie total absurd, weil sowas ließe sich nun digital wirklich viel besser lösen
und so dann sehe ich halt so, ja genau und jetzt digitaler Führerschein, ja dann müsst ihr hier nur so eine App runterladen. Und dann denke ich mir schon so,
Okay, eine App. Also,
App irgendwie eine App für den Corona-Ausweis, eine App für den Führerschein, so wie viele Apps kommen da noch dazu? 30 verschiedene Apps. Das wird niemals funktionieren. Was für eine App ist das? Dann denke ich mir so, okay, äh jetzt kommt hier so Führerschein, App,
von Verkehrsministerium Deutschland. Nein!
Viel Spaß in Frankreich mit deiner.
Ja genau, die heißt, ich sag's jetzt mal ganz hart, Ideallet. Du heißt die Idee Wallet.
Ja, klar, wir sind zu Nerds und wir wissen so, aha, okay, das soll eigentlich ID,
Wallet heißen. So, ja, weil das ist ja wieder eine ID in deiner Brieftasche. Aber ich meine, geh mal auf die Straße und frag mal, wie viele Leute wissen, wat, wat, wat, wat, wallet, äh, deutsch heißt oder ob Wallet irgendein Wort ist, was ihn irgendwas gibt in ihrem Leben. Keiner weiß das.
Zurecht. Das müsste man nämlich auch gar nicht wissen.
Na ja, bei Tim ist doch ganz klar, dass das ist einfach das ID Wallet vom Federal Department of Transportation.
Ja, wenn's mal so wäre, dass es hier von der Digital Enabling GmbH irgendwie rausgebracht, ja. Was ist denn eine.
Es ist eine GMBH, ich hab's dir die ganze Zeit gesagt, es ist alles eine GmbH.
Ach so, Deutschland ist doch eine GmbH,
Ja, aber das ist definitiv der falsche Name dafür. Also ich meine GmbH ist, dann ist sie sicherlich nicht entabelt. Ähm weißt du, was ich meine, ist so etwas wie,
staatliche Dokumente. Nachweisen auf deinem Telefon, das hat einfach von vorneherein,
ein mindestens europäischer Standard, wenn nicht gleich weltweiter Standard zu sein. Und wenn man das in solche Telefone reinkriegt, dann erhält man sich nicht mit irgendwelchen,
GmbHs, die was weiß ich, sieben Mitarbeiter haben vor sechs Monaten gegründet worden, als das Verkehrsministerium hat durchsickern lassen. Jetzt wollen wir irgendwie auch mal was machen,
Ja, keine Ahnung wie viel CDU Freunde da jetzt schon wieder äh dran beteiligt sind an diesem ganzen Projekt,
Dann setzt man einfach auf Standards, dann werden diese Standards entwickelt, dann können die das direkt ins Betriebssystem einbauen und fertig ist die Laube,
stellt sich auch raus, gibt so eine Funktion auch schon irgendwie in den Telefonen, also zumindest gibt's das bei Eiweiß, sicherlich auch äh bei Android, wenn nicht jetzt schon, dann bald,
und ähm damit ließe sich sowas natürlich auch machen, aber nein, jetzt wird erstmal eine App wieder irgendwie gelauncht von irgend so einer Bude. Und wir wissen schon, worauf worauf das hinausläuft,
dann läuft die nicht, dann funktioniert die nicht. Denkt doch nur mal an äh Ortan-Anwendungen irgendwie von eurer Bank.
Hör auf.
Secure, so ein Scheiß.
Den salzigen Finger in die Wunde tun, Tim, ne?
Ja, muss man.
Ja, also und aber das vielleicht noch ganz kurz.
Weil klar ist, dass was du eigentlich haben möchtest, ne, also was du eigentlich haben möchtest, ist mindestens eine EU weiter Standard, ja? Wie er übrigens, dürfen wir nicht vergessen, bei den digitalen Covid-Zertifikaten ja durchaus auch verabschiedet wurde.
Ähm.
Und dann gehen die aber hin und sagen, oh, ha, das sind, das ist ja auch aus wirtschaftlichen Überlegungen, dass man sagt, nee, komm, lass uns schon mal lieber hier ein ähm ähm Nägel mit äh Köpfen machen.
Damit wir ähm damit wir einen Vorsprung haben, damit wir vielleicht schon mal einfach eine Technologie definiert haben, weil wir sind ja total digital.
Und am besten funktioniert es dann über das stadtweite WLAN in Berlin. Ja, äh.
Na klar und das das sind natürlich die Ideen, den jetzigen ähm den den Unternehmen, die man da fördern möchte, ich meine Bundesdruckerei, ne. Ähm,
den den Einrichtungen, die man da fördern möchte, denen auch irgendwie ein Vorsprung zu geben, damit eventuell schon mal irgendwie Realitäten zu schaffen, die man im Nachhinein standardisiert
und da arbeiten aber natürlich dann jetzt die Sachen gegeneinander. Ich vermute, also ich meine, ich habe ja ähm vor einigen
Monaten war ja da auch noch mal diese Anhörung zum EP, also der soll ja ebenfalls aufs Handy, ebenfalls aufs Handy. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob also ich lese hier nichts davon, dass das die gleiche Technologie sein soll und dass sie da eine Vereinheitlichung anstreben oder ein ein internationalen Standard anstreben. Das äh stelle ich bisher nicht fest.
Ja? Und grade was du dann natürlich bei diesen digitalen Sachen hast was übrigens auch beim Impfpass ja vollständig verkackt wurde, ne? Auch auch absehbar verkackt.
Alle haben jetzt diesen Impfpass und es stellen auch wirklich Leute, die Ahnung haben, ja, die die jetzt nicht als digitale ähm Hinterwäldler wahrnimmst, die die stellen dir ganz normal im September die Frage, hör mal,
wie wir man zeigt ja zu diesen Impffass, aber wie verifizieren die Leute denn eigentlich, ne?
Habe ich das jetzt richtig verstanden, dass man dafür eine andere App braucht? Ja, hast du richtig verstanden, ne? Weiß keiner. Ich habe letztens hm musste ich meinen Impfpass zeigen.
Völlig verdattert, dass die kontrollierende Person nicht mit dem Finger aufs Display ging, um zu gucken, ob scrollt und nicht nur ein Screenshot ist, sondern,
tatsächlich ihr Kopfpasscheck rausholte und äh gescannt hat, ob der, ob der gültig ist. Ich bin, ich habe applaudiert, ich habe gesagt, das hätte ich ihnen gar nicht zugetraut, so wie sie aussehen, ne. Das wirklich das passiert dir ja nicht mehr oder hast,
hast du schon mal erlebt, dass jemand ernsthaft deinen Impfpass richtig kontrolliert hat?
Ja, ich habe das schon erlebt.
Und äh und Ausweis. Ja du in der in der Kneipe mit Wolfgang Kubicki, aber ich sage mal wirklich jetzt irgendwie jemand, also in.
Eier im Stadion.
Wobei auch da.
Da passieren ja eh.
In der einen Schlange.
Dann im Stadion.
In der einen schlagen, in der einen Schlange äh nimmt jemand sein Smartphone, ja und in einer anderen Schlange, direkt daneben äh sind das so Zertifikatsroller, wie ich's immer nenne,
ja, die dann irgendwie so aufm Telefon irgendwie rumscrollen wollen und dann äh frage ich so, ja und willst du nicht scannen.
Aber ich habe ja, ich habe ja keinen, ich habe ja keinen Scanner.
Ja? Also sie gehen davon aus, sie müssten jetzt irgendwie einen offiziellen Scanner äh in die Hand bekommen, also ne, brauchst keinen Scanner, du brauchst nur dein scheiß Telefon, sowas, was ja wohl haben. So,
Es ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen das Problem, weil natürlich mein mein Ziel ist natürlich wie alle anderen auch bei solchen Kontrollen.
Ins Stadion zu kommen.
Ich will, ich will da rein. Ich will jetzt hier irgendwie nicht noch äh Heckmeck haben und die Zeit ist eh schon knapp und so weiter und die anderen sind ja auch schon alle drin, weißt du, so Konzerte et cetera. Und das ist immer so ein bisschen das Problem. Aber ich habe mir jetzt meinen ähm.
Also man kann ja mittlerweile, also man bekommt ja sowieso eine ausgedruckte Version bei der Apotheke, die man ja erst eins kennt.
Das ist ja im Prinzip nichts anderes als der selbe Kot und die,
äh Pass, App und auch die Corona-Warn-App äh können jetzt auch wieder exportieren, also können wieder quasi das PDF da wieder draus machen,
dieser merkwürdige DIN A vier Falte Zettel ist, den man da irgendwie äh rausbekommt, auch ein bisschen skurril, äh warum das unbedingt jetzt in so einem A sechs Format zusammengefaltet werden soll, weil da ist irgendwie nix mit gewonnen, ne, anstatt einfach mal so eine normale.
Das Format von deinem normalen äh Impfpass. Und außerdem äh gibt es ähm gibt es äh ja jetzt auch schon Anbieter, die dir dann sagen, ja pass auf, wir drucken dir den QR-Code, wir campen dir den in äh in eine Checkkarte, dann hast du
hast du den in Hardware? Ist auch voll geil.
Ja, wobei das, glaube ich, verboten worden ist, irgendwie das Projekt. Auf jeden Fall habe ich mir dann selber diesen QR-Code einfach ausgedruckt und laminiert.
Ohne dass irgendwelche meiner Daten dadrauf zu sehen sind, sondern nur der QR-Code und noch so ein bisschen den Text daneben mit irgendwie, ja, ja, hier Zertifikat, das ist mir so halbwegs äh einen offiziellen Anklang hat. Und ähm wenn ich's mir sozusagen in dem Moment erlauben kann.
Ja? Weil es hat alles erstmal zu meinem Nachteil. Dann zeige ich halt immer erstmal das Ding. So. So halbwegs offiziell aus,
So und dann sollen sie damit irgendwie klar kommen. Äh kann ich nicht überprüfen, denn wieso kannst du hier überprüfen ey und dann das du dann dann kannst du diese Debatte aufmachen. Wenn man einfach Bock drauf hat irgendwie sich aufhalten zu lassen. Ja gut, aber es ist.
Wenn man Bock drauf.
Aber ich habe ein bisschen Verständnis auch dafür. Oft ist es halt so, die wissen's halt auch nicht anders. Andererseits gibt's halt auch welche, die müssten's halt besser wissen,
und machen's dann trotzdem nicht. Jetzt war ich irgendwie in Dortmund am Stadion, wo sie wirklich generalstabsmäßig,
um die Geschwindigkeit bei der Ticketkontrolle am Eingang zu erhöhen, haben sie so ums Stadion herum ganz viele, also ich habe mindestens so zwanzig gesehen,
Nein, nein, einfach so Menschen, die so eine äh so so ein Banner, so ein so ein ich bin ein Check-In, äh Fähnchen irgendwie so am Rücken festgeschnallt haben, dass man die irgendwie gut sehen kann
ja? Und dann kannst du da halt hingehen und dich quasi von ihnen schon mal autorisieren lassen, dann kriegst du so ein so ein Armbändchen, so nach dem Motto, ja hier äh Covid äh Zertifikat ist gecheckt, ne, weil das nach dieser zwei Gehregelung da äh läuft.
Ja, aber es ist natürlich auch alles nur so Smartphone-Scroller. In dem Moment hatte ich dann halt auch irgendwie so schönes Telefon in der Hand und dann so um äh,
Nee, muss aber jetzt rein, weil ist knapp. So, sonst hätte ich halt gerne den Tanz gemacht, ne? Und es müssen halt mehr diesen Tanz machen.
Das ist einfach schlimm.
Nun das, also das zeigt jetzt einfach nur, ne, das ist also, ist jetzt mal nicht ganz so stark zu traumatisieren, ist das halt eine neue Technologie. Der wurde den, die den Leuten einfach nicht erklärt wurde.
So und entsprechend gehen die damit auch um, ja. Ähm und jetzt haben wir halt einen Führerschein auf dem Handy.
Ja, aber es ist halt auch die Herangehensweise ist ja nicht nur dieses erklärt. Nein, es gibt jetzt die Koffpass-App.
Dann gibt's noch die Corona-Wallepp. Okay, gut, das kann ich irgendwie noch verstehen, dass man nochmal was zusätzliches machen will, damit man den Leuten irgendwie nicht unbedingt,
dass man sozusagen, ich weiß nicht genau, was die Intention ist. Und nach dem Motto, naja, die Corona-Warn-App, die macht ja nochmal was anderes und das ist ja auch nochmal
eigenes Thema und jetzt wollen wir den Leuten aber ermöglichen, diese Zertifikat benutzen zu können, ohne diese Corona-Warn-App-Debatte wieder hochzuziehen, obwohl es ja eigentlich eine gute Gelegenheit gewesen wäre, zu sagen, einfach ja, hier Corona-Zertifikat, Corona-Wandapp, installiere mal, dann hast du auch deinen scheiß Zertifikat,
ah, es sind nebenbei auch noch gleich die Funktionalität. Und dann gibt's noch eine zweite App. Die heißt dann Check.
Ja? Ist auch so wie. Also einfach.
Nennt doch die scheiß Teile mal so, wat machen auf Deutsch irgendwie? Und nicht immer diese kranken, englischen Abkürzungen oder die sich
kein Mensch irgendwas vorstellen kann. Menschen können einfach kein Englisch, das ist einfach so. Nein, so brauchst du aber noch eine zweite App. Und da frage ich mich,
Warum? Warum braucht man nochmal, nochmal eine App, die nichts anderes macht, als kennen. Hätte es nicht ein zweiter Button in der selben App auch noch getan? Natürlich hätte es das.
Macht mich wahnsinnig. Wer wer kommt auf sowas? Ja, als ob das ja was.
Es ist, es ist, es ist, wie es ist.
Ja, es ist wie es ist. Aber das sind doch IT-Entscheider. Ich meine, bitte.
Nein, sitzt nicht, das ist genau das Problem, es sind keine IT-Entscheider.
Aber hier, ich ich habe jetzt herausgefunden, wie du deinen digitalen Führerschein bekommst. Ganz einfach.
Na? Mhm.
Für das herunterladen, der Daten ist der Kartenführerschein nicht erforderlich.
Nutzer müssen sich lediglich per ID Wallet, ja, das ist die App mit ihrem Personalausweis und dessen Online-Funktion authentifizieren,
um einen QR-Code aufzurufen, dann lässt sich die App die Daten aus den zentralen Registern des KBA herunterladen und zeigt diese an. Also, du musst irgendwo mit deinem mit deinem,
Dein Ausweis, dich eine EID Authentifizierung machen, was auch ein ich meine, das ist ja ganz alltäglicher Ablauf für uns alle.
Klar, täglich.
Und dann kriegst du einen QR-Code und den musst du dann mit der App scannen. Also ich ich bin gespannt. So und dann, dann, weißt du, was du mich richtig unterhaltsam wird, Tim, ne? Du hast ja jetzt ähm.
Du hast jetzt irgendwie das die Probleme der Kopfpass-Check gezeigt, ne. So.
Ich bin ja äußerst gespannt, wie das demnächst in den Verkehrskontrollen wird, wenn die, wenn Polizisten und Polizisten.
Irgendwie eine eine Handy-App, deinen Führerschein kontrollieren soll.
So. Da kann ich mir auch schon vorstellen, dass du, dass du mit deinem laminierten QR-Code sehr viel Freude in äh vor allem dann mit Leuten, ja, die nicht einfach nur dumm sind, sondern dazu auch noch bewaffnet und gewaltaffin,
wunderschön. Ja, das wird doch wunderschön.
Das könnte doch toll werden, ja.
Ah okay, das ist also ich wäre vorsichtig. Ich ich glaube, ich nehme da lieber mein Sicherheit doch noch mal den Hardwareführerschein mit,
da irgendwie und bevor die Fahrt ein jedes Ende findet und die dir das Handy wegnehmen oder sowas. Das ist alles. Genau, ist ja auch das andere Problem, ne? Muss ihr Handy aus der Hand nehmen. Musst du Handy für entsperrt haben.
Etwas, was man ehrlich gesagt nicht unbedingt in der Nähe von Polizisten und Polizistinnen machen möchte. Seine Handy entsperren. Also ich meine, wo kommen wir denn hin? Soll ich mal das äh alles irgendwie nicht.
Ja oder so laminierte QR-Codes hast,
und zwar total kommentarlos, einfach nur so QR-Codes durch diese durchblätterst, zielgerichtet irgendwo hingehst und sagst, ja, Führerschein, ja, hier, kein Problem, aber hier ist der QR-Code. Steht alles drin, ja, hat der, hat Herr Scheuer gesagt. Jetzt habe ich gerade mal diese Idee Wallet.
Gestartet, um mal so zu gucken, wie so die die Onboarding äh experiments ist.
Und was will das Ding als erstes von einem, nachdem es einem irgendwie so grob mit einem hübschen Bildchen äh versucht hat zu erklären, wofür es eigentlich da ist?
Nee. Nein, du musst ja natürlich erstmal eine sechsstellige PIN einrichten. Ja, wieder so eine scheiß Pin mit der du was machst, du vergisst sie. Ja.
Dann stehst du in der auch scheiße in der in der Verkehrskontrolle.
Mann, ey, baut doch den Scheiß einfach ins Betriebssystem ein. Es kann doch so schwierig nicht sein, ey. Gott.
Naja, es wird, es wird sicherlich ein, ich sage, der Tim, der fit, das wird ein richtiges Erfolgsprojekt. Damit damit geht es jetzt los in Deutschland. Damit äh bricht jetzt die Digitalisierung über uns hinein.
Eingegeben und kommt dann erstmal Push-Servicefehler. Es konnte leider keine Verbindung mit dem Push-Dienst hergestellt werden. Neue Nachrichten werden bei geöffneter App alle 30 Sekunden abgerufen.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch, jetzt hast du einen Führerschein, der dir Bosch-Nachrichten geschickt. Ich war eigentlich ganz zufrieden, dass das Scheißding mich einfach in Ruhe gelassen hat, ne.
Nee, ich meine, das hat mich natürlich am Anfang gefragt, ob ich irgendwie Nachrichten dafür nehmen will, habe ich natürlich nein gesagt. So und deswegen kommt es wahrscheinlich dieser Fehler,
Es läuft die ganze Zeit irgendwie hier so Rädchen, denk, denk, denk, so, dreißig Sekunden rotiert hier irgendwie das Ding und tut jetzt erstmal gar nichts so, ja, rotiert Ding, grübel, was macht er jetzt irgendwie, berechnet der jetzt irgendwie
Zufallszahlen oder äh ist das schon dabei Bitcoin zu berechnen? Ich weiß es nicht. Das Ding tut jetzt einfach gar nicht.
Bei mir ist auch einfach nur dieses Warteding jetzt.
Ja, es kommt einfach nur Wartedingen, also müsste nicht ideal heißen, sondern es müsste ideal heißen.
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, die leiden einfach nur grade darunter, dass das jetzt mal ein paar Leute nutzen.
Ich meine, wie scheiße und schlecht ist sowas, wenn schon mal nur so das mal runterladen und mal starten und mal gucken, schon in die Hose geht?
Echt, also wirklich, Deutschland ist einfach ich kann, ich kann, ich kann es nur immer wieder nochmal sagen, ich,
habe die Hoffnung verloren. Es wird nichts mehr werden. Es wir werden es nicht hinbekommen. Deutschland muss sich mit Platz 50 bis Platz 78 in in jeglicher digitalen Weltrangliste abfinden,
Ja? Und wir feiern, wenn wir mal in die Top Forty kommen. Aber Bundesliga ist hier nichts mehr zu holen.
Ach je.
Digitale Versager, ey.
Dieses Warten hört echt nicht auf, ne.
Ist kaputt.
Guten Tag, allgemeine Verkehrskontrolle, Führerschein, Vorsicht, Papiere, bitte. Ja, kleinen Moment.
Ja, warten sie einfach noch ein bisschen. Okay, lass uns das äh lass uns das beenden.
Ja, damit äh sind wir auch schon fast am Ende der Sendung angelangt, ne.
Ja, genau. Kleine Terminhinweise hier ohne Jingle. Ich äh wir sind noch darauf hingewiesen worden. Werden den Film, alles ist eins außer der Null noch irgendwo nicht äh entdeckt hat und noch nicht hat sehen äh können. Und vielleicht in der Nähe von Schwerte wohnt.
Da gibt's die Möglichkeit dazu, denn.
Pferdes Sauerland, oder?
Ähm.
Sein, dass das zum Sauerland gehört. Jetzt muss ich das äh das ist doch, du kennst dich doch da aus in dieser Region. Ja, Sauerland äh haut hin, ne? So äh Süd äh östlich von Dortmund, ist das.
Fängt das wahrscheinlich schon an. Jetzt gibt's wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwie so bei Hagen ist das. Weiß nicht, ob das schon Sauerland ist oder ob das äh sach mal ist es.
Weiß ich nicht. Müssen wir gucken. Ja.
Auf dem Weg zum Sauerland auf jeden Fall wippen. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall dort gibt's am 9. Oktober eine Open Air Vorführung des Films. Alles ist eins.
Nee, im Süden von Schwerte, im Süden von Schwerte beginnt das Sauerland.
Okay, also das Tor zum Sauerland, Schwerte. Und für euch auch das Tor zu dem Film, alles eins außer der Null. Am neunten Oktober in Schwerte, in einer unhackbar, ein.
Sehr schön. Eintritt frei.
Geographisch wird die Stadt Schwerte nach der aktuellen Definition zum Ruhrgebiet gezählt.
Guck an. Also im Pot.
Na ja, also.
Ja warte, warte, warte. Ist das Ruhrgebiet jetzt nicht mehr der Pott oder was?
Ich werde es am, am, ja, ist okay, es ist, ich sage ja, geografisch wird das nach der aktuellen Definition zum Ruhrgebiet gezählt, aber so.
Ah, dann ist das halt so.
9zehnter Open Air in Schwerte. War cool.
Mhm. Gut. Da müssen wir am Ende der Sendung.
Meine ID Wallet ist leider hier nach wie vor ähm ohne.
Aber mir ist jetzt was gekommen.
Kurze Fehlermeldung, aber die konnte ich nicht lesen, dann war sie wieder weg.
Nee, jetzt äh jetzt möchte ich's auf meine Kamera zugreifen und ähm.
Ich sehe ihre Dokumente, Mustermann, eine Basis all die.
Ich hab's jetzt grad, ich hab die App jetzt einmal abgeschossen und jetzt soll ich 'ne neue PIN vergeben. Also die hat sich nicht gemerkt, also ist einfach.
Ich kann ja auch mein Covid-Zertifikat dazupacken. Ah, eine weitere App. Sehr schön. Na ja gut das war's.
So, wählt bitte was vernünftiges, Kinder.
Aber wählt. Wählt was vernünftiges aber wählt. Genau. Kann ich zu dir ins Wahllokal kommen? Nee, ne?
Na ja, mich haben sie ja hinten bei der Briefwahl. Also ich ich bin ja gut, da gucken weniger Leute hin, ne.
Stimmt. Okay, aber du sicherst das nach hinten ab, sozusagen.
Ich sehe, dass nach hinten ab. Ich habe auch schon ein paar Umschläge nochmal mit leider. Ja, nächste Sendung regen wir uns dann über das Wahlergebnis auf. Das wird bestimmt auch total schön.
Das wird richtig toll. Ich freue mich jetzt schon drauf. Okay, Leute, ihr wisst, was ihr zu tun habt. Bis bald.
Bis bald, ciao, ciao.